all right and we are finally
live the last word with laura cognito
and ebantus
fresh on that friday evening tip
what's going on e oh man dude i have
been
playing so much outriders lately it's
been a lot of fun we will get into that
uh before i deep dive into what's going
on here just a reminder for you guys if
you do listen on youtube
thank you guys whether it's on iron
lord's podcast oribanta's youtube
channel if you listen on one check out
the other one
make sure you guys drop a subscribe like
and all the good stuff there and also
remember we are on your audio platforms
so if you want to take us with you in
your phone on the go however you do
itunes spotify google play it's all out
there so definitely take a listen
um in on any of those platforms we are
out there usually pretty quick
so that being said uh all the front-end
stuff out of the way pass it back to you
sir
and uh we got a guest so who we got we
got somebody man so let's let's do this
right
welcome to the last word episode number
143
and it's glorious friday we're back in
front of the campfire for some more
looting shooter discussion
i'm extremely excited about our special
guests so we're going to get right into
it
i want to introduce a lord who is not
only a tremendous supporter of the last
word campfire and the iop
but whose positive energy and passion
for the destiny franchise
is truly infectious through our entire
gaming community
introducing the creating host of the
last city radio podcast
and owner of the p carlisle gaming
twitch channel
the lord of divinity who probably reps
that vex with the class
by making 8th yard fall off that map
live from nc and making his debut
at the campfire of the last word
mommy lord pcg aka
philip carlyle gaming how we doing sir
all right all right
all right really good excellent
performance
wonderful intro man i'm gonna cherish
that
for years to come salute to you sir
thank you
doing really well today no doubt that
long overdue
you've been talking for a while man glad
to have you at the campfire
big fan of yours your positivity the
community how you been man
yeah man been doing pretty good man uh
you know
just uh been sitting back looking at all
the things the wonderful things that
bungie has been doing
and uh just the community in general man
i think we're
we're so blessed to have a community
like this and especially what you guys
are doing
you know we always need something like
that someone who's positive who spreads
light
in a positive way about destiny and just
life as a gamer itself that's amazing
you know that's one of the things that
inspired me to do what i do
so salute to all of you guys love
love what you're doing love the positive
energy got a chance to work with you
cast at you on a few different shows and
stuff and absolutely yeah man you know
we had to do it we had to get you that
cat five but i'm gonna
set it off first with questions for the
for the great
pcg
yeah so uh i wanted to go back and kind
of touch on some of your gaming history
because you've
actually gone back through some games i
just like the mention of some of them
because you got a chance to play some
really special titles as you were
growing up
um and the ones that stick out for me
are especially the nintendo ones for
that so i just kind of wanted to see
what for you
like are your major standouts of like
i mean so super nintendo n64 like those
were
special consoles nes was for me too but
if those are your first two what are
your big standouts and
why like what why do those games like
sit as memories to you and what makes
them special
so i'll go back to uh as a small child i
used to watch
my my mom and uh my
aunts they would play uh they had
the super nintendo um and then
also at that time um around
it was probably like the late 90s we got
the uh
first playstation and as a kid
just messed around i did kind of mess it
up i'm sorry
you broke the playstation
i put cereal in it just mess it up oh my
kid i know
that's the worst thing you could ever do
so um at that time you know
didn't get a chance to play playstation
i missed that generation um
but we had the super nintendo and i
remember the first games that we played
was uh donkey kong the donkey kong
country series
oh that to me was that those games when
i tell you about donkey kong men
the the thought that they put into those
games is just
amazing man lost you have lost worlds
after you beat the regular game there's
so much things
there's so many levels you know to that
game that you
have to sit back and really take the
time to discover
and just the vastness of it it just drew
me in
um just all of number one two and three
men
i had a blast playing and then um
years later probably around the early
2000s
still had that my mom bought a nintendo
64.
i had the green edition the clear one
very rare uh-huh yeah i remember that
yeah
and at those times back in the day um
we all remember when gamestop was a
gamestop
it was funko land at the time funko led
marcos yeah yeah it was funko land at
the time
and um i remember she bought this and
the very first game that she brought up
was
i had mario kart and then i had uh
uh dunk kong64 and man
back in those times those graphics were
phenomenal like we was like oh man this
is next level i can't believe this this
is great
and um and it was just it blew us away
um
and from then i i got that was a fan
and then at that point i would say
when uh i started watching sonic x of
course
uh that was that's what their very first
time seeing sonic i've never seen i
never played the
genesis game at that point um watching
that said man
i would love to see i will i would love
it if there's a game out out there
and then lo and behold i finally got a
chance to get my hands on that sega
genesis
they was having all the fun when i had
master system it was not new genesis i
felt i felt better about myself
continue it's something that here's the
i love nintendo
no hate i love nintendo as well
something about
sega just brings they were just ahead of
their time
because the music that they brought to
those games was
out of this world man i mean
sonic because uh first game sonic 2 with
tails love
that love that that was one of my
favorites and uh
man i'm just just the the amount of
energy they put in that game man i fell
in love with it i was like this
is it this is it this is my game right
here
and ever since there i became a fan of
sega and
you know sonic i would get sonic every
day you name it i had
you know that's an interesting story
because um you know
usually how it went back in the day at
least for the people i knew like
you know the nintendo kids kind of
stayed in the nintendo
ecosystem you know what i'm saying and
it was almost like
civil war to like for mario gotta like
sonic or
sonic god so you have a kind of a unique
thing but i guess
back to e's question i know what he
wanted to ask you was more so like
you know what i know you said a couple
but like
were there any other standouts even
though i'm gonna say ken i loved your
sacred discussions
is there any other status on the
nintendo side for e because i know he
trying to get that
like he want to know what was those
games i was gonna say like you said
uh docking kong country is a big one and
if you actually appreciate the music in
sonic
my advice is go look up how the music in
donkey kong country was made
absolutely absolutely you know about all
that history
you know about the history
i didn't know about it until probably i
mean i didn't know about it for quite a
while so when i finally came across
like how it all worked and what they did
to make use of just a little bit of
memory they had
just when you figure that stuff out you
always get to see some of the older
classic games
again the constraints of cert
constraints actually make people more
creative sometimes
which is always really cool to see
through like whatever generation you get
into you're like okay
what creativity did they do here what
did they do here and then like it's
usually like
cool stuff like that or game breaking
things that are always like interesting
to find so
i've just always and i like donkey kong
carter's music is just classic like you
hear one of those
it sticks out so it's like that was a
big and i don't see a lot of people
mention it either that's what i was like
everybody's like that's a good point
mario world
mario brothers 3 marvel 64 it's like of
course but like when you said donkey
kong to country i was like
and those those games absolutely kicked
your butt yes
they were hard dude yeah they were no
jokes
so if you want to shout out every banana
and all that stuff oh yeah
i want to shout y'all out though because
to me i remember from looking at the
outside in when i didn't have it at
first
i thought those games graphically
were like whoa like it jumped off the
screen
i was just like i was like like at the
time it's like if i watched like some
pixar
type it looked amazing if i'm right e
was it though it was like the first game
with the expansion something or
did they have some time i can't remember
it i remember dunking down country
being like hey like mario kart super
mario world it's like these are like
real donkeys like what it was
or don't donkey kong like real monkeys
and i was like it was
it was a weird leap and i totally
remember that it's like 64 was cool but
like donkey got was like
how is this console doing this this yeah
i will tell you another thing though
there's another one that i really um i
really appreciate
as far as what really got me on nintendo
i don't mean i don't see people mention
this but
i was a big fan of this is my first what
i would call
rpg game a lot of people would say final
fantasy
and that has a warm place in my heart
too but
i will say if you ever got a chance to
play
mario and the legend of the seven stars
oh hundred percent that to me
oh is the best mario game that they have
ever put out
wow ever i like that that's a game i
wish i could chrono trigger is mine on
super nintendo and will be my rpg
but number two behind that for that era
mario super mario rpg and legend of the
seven stars
100 like i played the ever loving crap
out of that game
and i don't see it mentioned all the
time but whenever i see a mention i'm
like oh
please like uh yeah that would be i wish
i could see like a mario odyssey quality
version of that game it would be
just absolutely like blowing people away
and they've done paper marios and some
of the paper marios i've heard are very
good
but for me i never got around to all
like those but i was like just that one
at its time especially because it was
square enix like they did the true rpg
and i was like
they nailed it there's characters that
have been in there like gino and malo
that haven't been anything else and i
miss him and stuff
so i miss him i feel like i've missed
out on that one
um i've seen it everyone that talks
about it it's like revered
so i feel y'all i feel you i gotta
respect this one man
another question i got about your gaming
history that you you mentioned a certain
title
that uh really want my heart that you're
a big fan that i didn't know
was a mass effect absolutely i did not
know you see this is my glaring
glaring like hole in my history oh yeah
exactly yeah that's my that's my destiny
before that's well before that's the
okay so the question
i gotta ask is that oh what i know if
you paid attention to my twitter
you know what i'm about to ask you is
very controversial is a very polarizing
question
but it comes down to the trilogy and you
can answer any one of
three but if gunned to your head which
is the best mass effect
game okay
so there's no talking to nothing we need
a straight answer
your friendship will say he can't give
it 14 caveats
yeah i would say everyone's gonna hate
me on this one but i would say
number three and the reason why i say
number three
first number let me hear it because
here's here's how i look at it
if you think if you take remember no not
too much spoilers because e has not
played yeah
not community no doubt continue
so if you take it's for me and i played
one two and three i loved all of them
but number three it sets the stage
for like the avengers this is it
yes and and the reason why is because
we're following these people on this
journey
we're falling in love with the
characters every character shares
moments that you know you can embrace
and you can you can relate to
and think about it the tone that number
three sets up
it's like okay it's do or die
you're right we have to make a choice
now
or we are humanity is lost and i love
the way that is and that's something
that it's like you know what
i feel it i'm really feeling okay the
reaper's out here man this is
this is this is doing time we're gonna
be extinct if we don't deal with these
people and just the character building
and the gameplay they upgraded the
gameplay which was oh yeah
it's definitely the most advanced it's
definitely advanced i i i'm with
you all the way you're not
until we get to that ending which we
can't
that's right that's right that's right
the thing was
again despite everything you're saying
that i'm not in disagreement with
because
they literally learned everything from
the other two it
the the stage was set graphically it was
amazing
you you've been with these characters or
you lost some character
you know saying all the way up until
that point right and i'm with you
as far you would have be
all the way until the ending and i guess
my question
without spoiling is because if he
doesn't realize the ending was so
controversial oh no i know it was i
don't
know
history i remember the
yeah so i know that's a thing so here's
the question as
it's a trilogy and they do connect you
lose characters throughout you go
are the endings in one of two
cliffhangers do they wrap up little
tight bows
how much connection is between the games
okay
to know why three being is it a
big letdown of the trilogy or is the
ending of the others actually better on
their own three
argue to phillips point he's right
if you take the ending out for a second
just for a second
and you judge that ride from the start
of three
to before the end which is still a long
thing
it is one of the most amazing
experiences you ever experienced right
they they
merge everything now to your question
part one
kind of rap with a bow right and two
started like oh wow this is something
going on now this is something else
right two ends on a cliffhanger so to
speak
right yeah okay and then three takes
that off so that that's where that
is i guess the only thing i would come
from is again my original question to
you
phil was just that you know with the
vitriol of the
ending you didn't seem to hold that
against it
you were satisfied the journey the
journey is better than the ending is
that the key
is that one of those yes big time in
three in my opinion in my opinion but
this is
he said three is his favorite so he
gotta he gotta sell me now i need to
know why
that ending affect him that much so when
it came to the ending
yeah that as far as the ending yeah it's
one of those things where it's like
how i don't know how i can take this
because the way they set it up
is like okay from the beginning
when you first start number three you
have to collect all these assets you
have to get all these assets by the time
you reach to the end
it all makes sense and if i'm not it
correct me on that if i'm wrong
when you choose one of the endings
shepard actually
ends up living one one of
crazy spoiler we're going crazy spoiling
i'm trying to be nice
we got to be respectful because he does
not know what we talk about and we're
going crazy
i mean i'm 20 years late so i was like
yeah but still i will i want those to be
a surprise
again if you could generalize it you're
without going into detail with that
i would say um for a general
journalization
okay you were okay with everything i
would say um
it did kind of leave room for a sequel
in a way
okay the way the way that it ended i
i was upset at first but i understood
because i was like okay
maybe they might just have something
planned where there's a sequel that that
they're working on but when they're not
trying to know what but we know there
wasn't years later so why are you still
accepted
right i gotta get right but there's a
rumor there's there's been some rumors
flying around
about in the studios that they're going
to make a new one
but it's going to be kind of like an
adaptation of
kind of like after master victory in a
way
andromeda really wasn't it really wasn't
a okay that's the redheaded step child
we don't talk about that
exactly that right there we put that to
the side
but he's in his own world
a proper number four would be
possibly what they're trying to make
right now so
we gotta keep our we gotta keep our
minds open you know
anything can happen but you're probably
optimistic
listen when we said you about you are
positive may salute you
respect disagree but i respect where you
come from
that's i just had to answer the best
question for you oh yeah you what you
got
uh yeah and of course obviously after
those games kind of set you up in the
world of sci-pi
sci-fi and rpgs you just don't seem like
you have a ton of specific like shooter
background but obviously destiny was it
more just the sci-fi
aspect and you like and then it just got
it hooked it's hooks in you how did you
what caused you to like go from
something like mass effect third person
shooter more deep rpg
how did you feel when when you went into
destiny the first time was it everything
you hoped for was it
missing some pieces after say like the
greatness of a mass effect like
where did it fall first because destiny
has been a roller coaster over the years
but right
absolutely well i will tell you this i
wanted to save this for
the talking purposes i didn't add that
in on purpose so
i actually my shooters begin um
i would say i used to play on the
gamecube star fox
and there was a shooter you're right
everybody remember star fox assault
star fox uh adventures all that type of
stuff um i got into that and then
when i got the wii of course you know um
playing call of duty for the first time
black ops one
that's what kind of got me into the
shooters in a way
but going fast forward to like uh
when i got to ps3 um i started playing
drake's uncharted and i started getting
into
other call of duties and my my uh
sister's boyfriend at the time he had an
xbox
and that's how i got introduced to halo
3 reach and all that
started playing that stuff i love those
i love those
um it's just for some reason man uh
bungie just had that
that glow and you could tell that glow
from from reach to number three
going up to halo uh before they decided
to give it to three four three
uh it it's just something about those
man
just phenomenal work and that's what
kind of drew me to
kind of like games like mass effect i'm
playing
with those i'm scared mass effect man
this is the gameplay the guns are
nice and that's one thing that caught me
because
mass effect they have some wonderful
looking and like they feel good the guns
feel amazing
and that's one thing that i was looking
for and then when they
introduced destiny one oh and i remember
myself
man but we're going to talk about
gunplay yeah you're gonna talk about
that
that's the one i've got a chance to try
debatable
ps3 i said okay let me try this out
choosing trying to figure out what class
i wanted to run i was like hmm
i'm looking at warlock i'm looking at
tight the hunter i'm like
i mean they could look cool but i ain't
feeling them right now
chose titan that tight oh yeah shows
tight
man it blew me away just the fact the
way
that they just okay we go from first
person we go to the third person at
times
yeah when they do it yeah that's a good
point epic man
and and that drew me into because it for
me it had that rpg aspect to it
which i one thing that i really like and
i i do feel like
um mass effect has that too um
to a certain extent where you have to
make sure you're
you're maxing out your shields you got
to make sure you're doing this and that
and um
when it came to destiny man it had that
that that one little thing i was looking
for and that's what really drew me into
it
um playing dash i was like man i love
this i love when it's going the story
wasn't there like you all wanted to at
first
you know every time we know what
happened but um
you know as far as the game play man i'm
telling
i had a blast playing it and i was like
i gotta get this game
i gotta get this game and i remember i
ended up getting the game right around
the time
dark below was about to come out so i
finally got the game at that point
yeah and his favorite oh yeah crotazine
oh yeah no it's not that code is it i
know i'm not number one
i'm just teasing it i hate that it's
even that high for him but i have to
continue
i gotta respect it i let you live in the
world of rose tinted glasses it's fine
[Laughter]
we get to see how this thing holds up
not too long from now so i'd be very
curious
i wonder why the ring code is in first
hmm
it is a glorified grand master nightfall
strike well then you know
i didn't say it
he said you gotta only preach it right
now continue
this parade that came out in three
months that was pretty good
fair enough fair enough fair enough what
do you feel
from destiny and it i could tell i said
you know what
because i at that time when destiny was
getting ready to come out
uh i was playing master effect heavy
like i would play
every day i would start from the first
game finish it all the way okay i'm
gonna start back in the first game
i was doing that and um and also
i was also playing uh dc universe online
like i was heavy dc
universal my guy too so rpg aspects that
was my favorite that's my thing
um and then um i said you know what this
this game it feels different
i mean it plays different it has that
feel that i want
that master back has but the game it's
like this thing has potential
and i knew right then i was like this
game is going to be
something monumental for years ago
i felt it right then and i and i said i
want to be there to ride the wave
because i knew that this game was taking
off the
just being able to go with the fire team
i remember the first time of doing
doing a strike valles man that thing
right
there man i was nervous but i
loved every minute of it and it it just
brought that feel man
that feel man it just there's something
about it and
i kept i kept going and riding the train
man here i am now
here you are man no no i hear you i
totally hear you i mean for for a lot of
people
based on what you're saying you know a
lot of people felt the same way when you
know
you played it whether it be the gun play
you know the space
opera aspect the sky boxes you know the
music
it was just this and then you said the
character choices trust me
before people don't realize before i
pick warlock i
stood on that character screen for a
good 20 minutes
yeah and i just kept cycling back and i
was this close to picking tight
i was cause i'm like all right halo you
know
brother you know you know it should
technically be me right i was just like
but then i just saw that glow in the
thinking hey i don't know what about the
warlock with the glow in hand intrigued
me personally
but i feel you everybody had that choice
when you stood at that character screen
and i stood there for a while and they
were very compelling choices and other
things
i like ninjas sort of hunted did appeal
to me too you know i mean so it was it
was a tough decision picking warlock for
me
but to your point with um yeah just the
gun play and
you did fee i remember being in i was in
the alpha and i remember being in the
alpha and being like yo this
feels special and just like you know
i've been walking around the tower i'm
like wait a minute that's a that's a
live person
in the game like this is my first kind
of mmo light experience so
i'm with you you did feel something
was was special happening and now i feel
you on that part
um quick destiny question i had to ask
you because you mentioned titan was um
before you get into your background i
just wanted to ask you favorite
titan as far as lore i always have to
ask to tighten this because i feel i
feel like titans
titan means you guys have great titan
characters and i want to know what titan
you
who's your fa who's the one you
gravitate towards out of all
let's see um so does it have to be from
destiny 1 or just that's
george any titan any titan destiny 1 2
doesn't matter
who is the guy the titan you relate to
that's your favorite
i would say i gotta say saladin because
the reason why i say saladin
is because just the lore behind him
and we all got we we all got to keep it
real when we saw that cinematic
oh [ __ ] you seen silent with that axe
and he running with his dogs
dogs yeah yeah oh man yeah man
that was epic just seeing it in his
story
and man just uh just about the iron
lords in general man
i love that whole story arc with seba
and uh which right now we got this
movement going on there i'm sure
everyone is seeing right now but uh you
know saladin
he he's a guy he's a man i feel like
he's like the captain america in a way
um in destiny because he's like he's a
man out of time
and yeah yeah that's a good point that's
actually a great analogy yeah
it's a good analogy i didn't think about
it like that you're right he's trying to
cope with
the loss of of just um you know his
his team his iron lords yeah and he's
just coping he's going through life
going to
a next battle to a next battle he hasn't
had time to really grieve properly
and and really really kind of like just
open himself
up um as we've seen in the lore uh like
i said i'm a big lord god too
and just in a little while all right
cora talking to saladin
seeing that the iron lords temple just a
mess and you know
he's just been kind of sulking and he's
going different battles he haven't
really
stepped out amongst the other guardians
and training them for a new generation
of iron lords
yet but he is um it's just
he reminds me of how captain america is
he woke up in the eyes
he's trying to adjust to what's going on
around him and uh
you know he realized that the people
that he knew in the past they're all
gone they're dead
you know so he has to adjust to this new
feeling so
i really connect with uh with salon like
that and he's
he's a very interesting titan for sure
oh respect to choice respect to choice
yeah i was like we got a lot to cover
but i still wanted to ask like your
other piece
that like i mean obviously dusty's had
his hooks in for a while
podcasting that's like one pillar that
you definitely have like delve into
want to do a lot about uh how did you
get into it was it destiny specific that
kind of got you hooked
then like what is kind of now your stuff
that you like to cover so kind of your
podcasting history
and just what got you in and you know
just what you've been through in the
world of podcasting since obviously
you're on one now
yes um so my love for podcasting came
when i started this was like i would say
uh
war mine post war mine okay almost pre
forsaken okay right before the
turnaround yeah yeah i started watching
uh
i started watching i was like you know
what i never really got a chance to
listen
i i was like there's so many podcasts
out there because i would watch gaming
podcasts
off and on but um i was like i want to
see if there there's destiny podcast out
there
and then uh guardian radio i see already
because i subscribed to mason mason sean
but i never got a chance to watch
um garden radio so i was like okay let
me watch it
and drew me and i said man i like this
episode of discussions
that i want to you know talk about yeah
and i would listen to
people and they give their take on the
swab or something going on with destiny
and i was like you know what i got some
ideas and i was like i was sitting down
i was like
i really want to i want to start doing
this so by the time forsaken
um rolled around we're probably we're
talking like maybe
uh november november to be exact um
that's when i found anger
and i started i said you know what let
me start podcasting i want to do this
and around i think if i'm not mistaken
around that time that's when the
activision thing started to
kind of start taking its toll and then
they started to split
um and that's when mark turcotte went on
you guys show and
i watched that show and uh i said man
this
these guys are great man who is these
guys man
and and and i was like i was hooked then
i said
that build my passion for because i was
like i want to start this so i was like
i got to think of a name so i was like
you know what
let me do let me do the last city since
it's it's destiny related so
okay let me do the last city radio and
um
i started yeah it was just me um at
first um
i started doing i would do the 12 every
week and just give my little take two
cents on it and then
over time i got to the point where i
started
searching for you know co-host and uh
i got a shout out my boy ronin uh 503
you're listening appreciate you man
um for hanging with me um
kg for life i i had so many guys that uh
uh that was hungry they was like yeah
man let's do this
and over time we started making
full-length podcasts about destiny and
having wonderful discussions
started getting guests on guys small
streamers
um uh like a blue viper tv
great guy and um just being
it's been going ever since to the point
where i've started to get noticed
by people and uh that's that was truly
an honor and then
just listening to the iron lords every
sunday i was like you know what
i don't want to just these guys are
inspiring i don't want to just do
destiny i want to
capture other game gaming things out
there too
so i decided to um split up shows
i said okay saturday is called destiny
day
and then on um sundays
i say okay i'm gonna do all gaming all
things gaming roundtable
okay we bring different news about xbox
playstation switch you name it
we're gonna bring the news to people and
uh it really started getting popular
and uh i was excited man um and
just listening to you guys man
definitely especially
the iron lords man solid guys man i
listen to other podcasts i love
other gaming pockets but nothing comes
close to the iron lures podcast i just
thank you brother nothing comes close
man
nothing comes close thank you really
amazing very very humbling
i didn't know that when he's going
through your story and um
kind of surreal for me because you know
i feel like i haven't been doing it
as long as as other people but um it
means a lot it means a lot you know
because um
you know he knows you know i even i had
my flesh i would relay to e like damn i
feel like
you know if people gave us a chance and
just listened and you know
he was just like you know just stick
with it and stick with it you know kind
of thing and um you know he's an
inspiration because i look at
you know his growth and how you know how
huge he got and and
yeah a lot of key moments for him that i
was like wow like that is special i
remember the whisper
one specifically you know i'm saying the
whisper video yeah
yeah like for me so it was always he
he doesn't really like the way like we
all inspire each other that's basically
what i'm getting at
is that yeah you know me looking to him
and saying wow
you know he's cool he's tangible that i
can talk to because
let's be real we know in these
communities sometimes
you know people act a little hollywood
and he's still the same person i was
when i met him at guardian con to this
day he has not changed that's why that's
my brother right there so
to see his growth it was inspiring and i
remember i remember when he was on dcp
i was proud as hell i was like he got
his jersey he got his
his face revealed you know what i'm
saying so i was just like that's dope
and and for us
you know we just put our little spin on
it and just try to be
fun and creative and obviously do our
online podcast
which was you know more than just
destiny and you know to hear someone
like you say yo
i watched you and you know that kind of
inspired me that
it really means a lot i want to thank
you but i've never heard that really on
a stream from someone and um
to know that about your story is cool
and um yeah man you're cool
you're cool dude man i like to like i
said we always gonna build and and help
you help you with the growth because
you're doing it the right way you're
staying positive there's no negative
foolishness and you got passion for the
game you got passion for the game
you got to be at the campfire man so
salute salute to you and thank you thank
you for that that meant a lot
thank you welcome no doubt no doubt
so we got a lot to talk about yeah so we
got to get into it because i'm i'm
jumping at the bit with the outriders
we're chopping at the bit we're just
going to a destiny
but um email let's set it up bro we got
to get into it man
yeah um so i guess the question is where
do you guys want to start do you want to
go
destiny first out writers at the end or
what's fresher in your mind what do you
guys want to hit on
i'm whatever i mean we could what i'm
i'm so excited to talk about whatever
because i'm excited about our writers i
want to talk about it i'm excited about
the news of that we can leave it to the
chat would you that was gonna say
i think yeah writers might be bigger and
just kind of the general
yeah like if you guys want to knock out
the destiny stuff first you know we're
standing there and then outrageous is
obviously the big news because
destiny's got some stuff but not quite
as crazy so correct right
right um that being said so we got a
swab this week but the big thing that
happened this week was
the new strike in the grand masters so
proving grounds
was last week's time in the strike and
then
this week we got to see what it was like
in the world of grand master
and it's been a spicy one for a lot of
people people have been going for
palindromes
and i haven't obviously had a chance to
get into it i've been
otherwise occupied yes yes but i was
curious what you guys have seen
if you guys have like checked out videos
anything like that thoughts about
just like how it is like how the
grandmaster is if you've got any
thoughts what you've seen
is it worth it that type of stuff where
you guys where are you guys at on the
new proving grounds
and just it seems like they've
definitely made a tough one
do you think what you thinking um so
yeah
i got a chance to jump into uh just the
nightfall strike the master nightfall of
uh
proving grounds and man i gotta tell you
man that's by far
the hardest strike um that they've ever
put out
facts in destiny 2. that thing right
there man just trying to
get past the beginning is the hardest
part because
everything everybody's shooting at you
man you can't
it's so hard to try to i mean
everybody's thinking of different stress
oh man okay let's use this let's try to
put divinity out
okay let's let's use sky burners oh
let's do this
man it is so hard trying to get i love
it
because we haven't really had one
like this in a while man we haven't had
a strike like this
and uh they really knocked it out of the
park
i must say the beginning of the end um
you know
the fonda music oh man they they pulled
off that old music from uh
was it the dutch giants piece oh man
remix it
epic um being in a tank that living tank
uh just the experience the mechanics
that you have to do
it's an amazing experience man and um
the only thing that i got a nick pick is
why didn't they make a a nightfall
specific
weapon to that strike why
not make something about that not be
anything
i mean there's been they've had multiple
opportunities to throw just make a
couple more weapons or something like
that
and they had the adepts that they wanted
to bring back this season of rotation
but be cool to be like
i mean you want to get people to really
kill themselves over a new a new strike
that's tough
put a unique one that people are like oh
it's going to be palindrome and then
they're like
what's this like can you imagine how
much the community would have actually
lost their mind if there was a new
weapon
just on proving grounds i mean people
would have been really torn to play out
writers and that it would have been
interesting but like that would have
been yeah
because i mean for me obviously i'm
doing other things but i was like
there's a lot of people who wanted to do
gm's and then jumping out riders
they're like destiny would have been
packed to that day so it's just it i
feel
you are correct that is a missed
opportunity would have been a cool
little surprise
would have been nice yeah i mean i
didn't get a chance to do the uh the
grand master version i just
actually just did you know a higher
level of a higher knife
on one underneath yep and i must admit
you know even that that level
i was like man this little it's a little
tough man it's
because you got that open space in the
beginning like phil was saying
everything is coming at you because it's
kind of battleground style yep
right that beginning part it's literally
like the battleground then the door's
open you get in there
and for me the different waves you know
there's that wave when you're
inside after you you know you do the
drops with the with the um
the little orb thing underneath or
whatever and there's
there's like two sections there the one
before you go
up to face the boss like again there's a
slot is that the tanks come out
like there's not a lot of respite
you know it's on and cracking from all
sides
and dudes are hitting hard so i'm like
damn i don't even want to
know what to do like like grand master
you know saying so that part right there
and i'm gonna keep it real like
that fighting that cabal champion at the
end
but then you got the fireball thing and
then you got he want to jump back
and then you got the you got barrier
champions coming out
and unstoppables running out and i'm
like
this ain't even grand master and i'm
like i was playing with uh
obviously i was playing with two um you
know i was playing with two randos on
one joint but
i was saying to myself i could i cuz i
saw the commentary on twitter
and people were like yo but then there
was some expert guys like oh
all you guys got to do is such and such
and such but i will say this i feel
that's just
i would in my opinion based on what i've
seen i felt that what felt like this
smaller percentage of players who were
kind of who are very well versed who
who run it but i i got the feeling that
this thing
is breaking a lot of people based on
what i heard so i don't know you got to
tell me e
from what you heard what you saw if you
got a chance to play
yeah i mean i just went through and i
was playing i did it part of the story
because obviously it was part of the
really cool cutscene we had last week
which was awesome to see and we knew the
gm was going to turn this time so you
got your little
kind of preview thing um
but yeah just going through there like
the experience of
jumping over like the tank treads and
that little area where there's not a lot
of room to move which was cool look but
you're like
this isn't a lot of room the double
tanks i'm like you put champions of this
room it's going to be hell and then the
boss room
it's the boss room there is no next to
no place
right and then and now they took her
they took out the cheese spot so people
can't
cheese it anymore yeah so i was like now
if you're going to go fight that thing
normal
i know there are people um i know live
mondo he's one of the guys i follow
he definitely puts some work in he's
like season pass rank 4 55. i was like
dude
crazy town uh esoteric of course you
know did but it's just like
but still it's like there are it's to a
point it's
it yeah i've heard some pretty brutal
stories about that one for sure because
once some people are like hey here's an
easy way to do it now the cheese is gone
i want to go see people who were
cheesing before be like what's it like
now
thank you thank you exactly because they
they hitting people with the all you got
to do
and i'm like yeah that's an exploit you
know what i'm saying so
now that that's going like exactly i
want to see down like what's going on i
mean
look you know it's there i agree with
phil though in the sense that um
you know for that level you you would
kind of hope that it would have been
some strike specific lewd or
you know someone i'm thinking chester
they're repairing also something that
kind of
you know rewards you also that's kind of
themed cabal like maybe as well
you know with the drops i mean the good
thing is it was a only deposit
i'll give you a credit it was a double
night for drop week
right yeah i mean i think somebody was
like oh this is cute it's a double
nightfall because it's absolutely
destroying you so
yeah yeah so you know you got that but
um yeah
i'm with everything he said he uh you
know it's it's interesting now to see
you know um what not that the exploits
remove what's really going on with these
clears now
let's let's see let's go door down here
that's what i got for it
what else we got uh so i mean that one
started the week i was like okay you got
a spicy gm
and then we had a tweet come out from
bungie help on the same day
saying on the season of the chosen
calendar proving grounds nightfall was
listed as free to all players
this is incorrect and players must own
beyond light and the season of the
chosen past to access this nightfall
i did not see that like coming
this late in the game especially to be
like oh by the way now it's supposed to
be there
oops like well for one how long has the
calendar been out there i know that's a
thing and that's probably like a minor
thing to overlook but
this is honestly probably the first time
i can remember where a season pass
actually limited a strike
am i is that correct
yeah uh i think so i think so because
it said that in the calendar when we
looked at the calendar
it did say oh it would be free to play
for
everyone after it went live
that week prior to it and they
it seemed like they played switcheroo
and that's
not good it really isn't
yeah it's interesting it was it was
interesting verbage because i
i thought the same thing like i thought
that it was supposed to be
free to all players and then they had to
make a retraction
you know to say that it's not so yeah
i mean that that is interesting um i
don't know how i feel about that
yeah i mean so the free to all players
the strike is in the playlist there's a
rotation you may come across
it but to access the nightfall specific
to the season pass it's just
it's strikes one of those things that
are general access they're one of those
things you again people have already
complained the strike list is too small
like that type of thing and then you're
like then you limit it this it just
seems like an odd move
and i feel like we've had a couple of
these little
i don't want to say nickel and diming
but i'm like we're gonna get to the next
one
there are a couple moments where it's
felt a little bit and i'm like
i i don't want them to like they're
skirting the line on little stuff and
it's not as bad
right now because most people at this
point probably have a season
but i just am worried like it's one of
those i know it's the slippery slopes
the wrong word but it's just one of
those like
this is one thing and unfortunately this
also for like
advertising purposes like if it truly
says you get it for free a week later
and then you have to change it now it's
like now i can't do the nightfall period
like
that's literally advertising that's like
false so that's saying
yeah that's kind of a tough spot when
you get to just what you get what you
pay for like
hey it's like i still have destiny 2 i'm
supposed to get this no you don't it's
like i guess it's free i guess it's
their choice but still it's like
there's weird little it's just the feels
that felt a little off when i read that
i was like i was
just about to say it and w prescott says
took the words
right out about i was literally gonna
say this feel like a night
night for paywall and and he said it
best he said what i don't get is now we
have
paid they have paywalled the conqueror
title
but won't pay wall entry to trials and i
am better but we caught it
that's where the pay would need to be
right right so we could get
the damn cheaters out the damn game
right so tell me we would be okay with
that paywall right but they won't play
the wall
and it's weird because it's like then
why get i mean listen we're happy that
players that don't have the season class
actually play proven guns we're happy
for that
but in a way it's like okay you could do
it but you can't do the same thing with
just a higher difficulty
like it's just very strange and it's
like it's like
why you don't say like in a sense like
why
what's the thought process i'm just i'm
trying to be nice like what's the
thought process to say right
you know we you need to be a season pass
owner to access
a nightfall version of
strike like what what's the what's the
prestige besides
i guess the title but it's just weird i
i i
that it actually confused me very
confusing
i think when it comes to that it's kind
of like saying
okay you're hired for the job right
but you can work but you got to pay for
your clothes
it it don't really make sense um
that's it looks like a bad pr move or
something something
something went wrong with the
communication um
because what it says on the calendar
should if you're gonna say you're gonna
do something you have to do it dang
cause now can't legally someone be like
yo
bungie you said i have this now yes they
may say legally they have the right to
change
maybe something contraction they could
say like it's a live service game they
can do whatever you like
yeah we could do that but it is it is
messed up if
let's just say you're a new person and
you you were interested in seasons of
chosen so you know let me see what it
has to offer
and then you looked at that initial road
map
yep after and you said oh i'm gonna get
this i'm gonna get that
it doesn't feel good to now have that
taken away
and say well you gotta get in that
season pass for that ten dollars
if you want to get in there yeah i guess
the other question is when does it hit
the list like or when does
how what about next season is it in
their next season
because now remember it's like if you
want to go play
the crypto lift hunts you have to still
go buy
season of the hunt to go do that
storyline of quest so to go
if you want to play the nightfall if
it's in the rotation between season 14
or season 15 which are potentially going
to be some longer seasons
is there a week every so often you're
just like nope can't do the nightfall
this week because i
i didn't buy that season because they're
great
it's a great season i recommend
everybody to buy it experience the story
and all that stuff yeah but
if for some reason you didn't like four
months from now and you're like
wait i can't do the nightfall because
why so what
yeah that's i guess another piece when
it comes to when does it actually cross
that threshold of
when it's okay to go like that's just a
weird one
yeah it's just strange that that was
strange the fact that they had to
come out with verbage to kind of explain
it you know
it it it is interesting it is
interesting yeah
very strange boom but we got we got more
other movies yeah we got to talk about
it yeah we'll go go with
whatever what is something in mind what
do you got what do you got oh well i i
um
based on twitter and uh the latest from
you know dylan and the guys and they
were talking about
modifications right we were talking
about yeah you know
um future ways of handling things and
you know we got a preview of uh
what will be coming in the season we get
to see the name yet but we got the
previews from
that ada will be returning to the tower
she's going to be offering a lot of
quality of life stuff
you know they talked about um transmog
system with armor synthesis which is
fire which is far away excited about
that
you know 801 will also become the vendor
who delivers a variety of armor-focused
items and upgrade each day
you sell one random chosen armament from
the general armor slot
and groups and then randomly chosen
combat style armament
which would be the charge with light the
warming cell group stuff
and it should make it easier for players
who missed that in the past to get their
hands on some of the iron the armor mods
from year three
then it said additionally on a weekly
basis eta one will
sell armor set randley from the world
loop pool with a stack roll that
also changes on a weekly basis very cool
finally ada will also sell armor upgrade
materials
upgrade modules prisms and shards in the
same way that banshee does so when i
read that okay so i want to know okay
what's going on with banshee now
so as as same with ada branch is going
to get revisions to his inventory
gunsmith will no longer sell armor mods
or
what would retain the rest of the items
that he currently sells additionally on
a weekly basis banshee will sell a
selection of six weapons
randomly chosen weapons in the world
loop pool
two weapons each from the kinetic energy
and power slots with perk rolls on each
weapon
that are randomly determined at the
start of the week d1 vibes
kind of fire oh yes yes we're gonna get
to that so at each weekly reset
when you log in you can head to the
tower and see what the gunsmith is
selling and maybe pick up a weapon
you've been looking for with a role so
before
i get to what i really want to talk
about the next part i want to ask you
guys
how are you guys processing aydah coming
back with this role bungie's
i mean bungie buying banshees new role
how do you guys feel about that first
phillip man you're up what do you got uh
so
uh i think it's a great
it's a very unique move um when it comes
to that because uh
ada coming back that's awesome and
introducing transmog
we all been waiting for that for a long
time so
i mean that from that's the one
absolutely i'm
i'm with you on that now as far as the
moss um
i mean i would say that's cool um it's
cool
uh that they're just basically saying
that hey you don't get this job banshee
anymore
okay we hire eight or one okay cool
that's yeah
right the banshee poor went out to the
banshee 44 mods twitter account
they were literally crying because
there's like i guess i'm useless now
i had the six guns in the thing yeah but
literally it's banshee 44 months
a lot of people would actually just go
and retweet to be like hey selling this
today so it's like
there are other ways to get it i just
saw the poured out i was like yeah
that's kind of done yeah
rip yeah change the name
yeah they said that stuff was taken as
soon as they went to look
oh i feel for them
yeah and and think about it it's just
like okay
now like you said we're feeling the
vibes from destiny one how they did it
back in destiny one when it came to
defenders
um but they go to random role you each
week different weapons
different roles on them okay i'm feeling
that i like that
and i i would actually thought they
would have done that
you know throughout not just with
banshee but shax needs to have something
like that
okay the drifter's got a ton of weapons
that he needs to go ahead okay i can
roll up
a update on trust okay could up-to-date
trust
you know different things like that they
should have been doing that
um and like i said okay they trinkled
out a little bit
um when it came to the uh what is it the
uh
the new monarchy and you know
those weapons are still sitting there
collecting dust
i mean we they pulled a little bit out
but they could have done it like the one
where
you go to them okay if you want to
pledge whatever
it's not a whole big deal here's a ton
of weapons and here's a ton of
armor says that you can pull random
rolls each week is different
cool uh just doing it with banshee aida
is just not
i mean it's great but it's like well we
should
we should have been doing this you know
we have many expansions to to
pull this one out of the bag like zavala
he's sitting there
why don't he have a upgrade module
shards and stuff like that and weapons
to pool for the week
i suppose it's just right now shaq's
kind of right and uh
yeah yeah yeah it's interesting that
zavala didn't get that treatment i guess
exactly he's interested mm-hmm so even
just again about this
role with uh ada you know and banshee
you know in the mod situation like what
are you feeling about this this stuff
specifically
uh i mean it sounds like if i read each
day 801 will now sell one randomly
chosen armor mod so that's like the
bigger pool of like
weapon dexterity and scavenger that's
that type of stuff right and then you
have
one randomly chosen combat style which
is what
most people tend to be going after i
still wish there would be like
i don't know why it still has i know
it's like this is the
player service of respecting a new
player's time or giving options
versus make you log in every day
that's still like the randomly chosen
mod rotating through every day you gotta
check
you stay connected to our game you got
to keep that destiny patch still on
like it's still there and that's like
that's one of those when i'm just like
you can't be like just mods just go to
an entire sheet i can look like
a you know four by eight square of like
shaders when i go to
master a whole that i can sell for
glimmer you're telling me there can't be
just like pages of mods like you got
them you got to buy them
it's just i know the random rotation's
there and at some point people are
getting i like the combat style being
separate because those are the ones that
people
need to not be like yeah in the mix of
like 50 mods like now it's a shorter
list which is good right
it's still one of those need to need to
check in on the daily need to stay
attached to the twitter still need to be
i know they're trying
and that's one of those things but it's
like it's hard to knock them sometimes
because they have built a great
community around
some of these types of decisions to keep
people
connected and never too far from their
world but like
still you know even if it's a random
combat style mod and you start adding up
everything from charged with light stuff
like that
still could be a month before somebody
gets one you go out of town for vacation
something like that it goes through
you're two months away
there's enough where it's a long enough
time and if you go on vacation at a
certain point for a new player
you could miss an important one and not
due to and not still have much so it's
like
i still wish somewhere there was a way
to get a little more choice i guess or
have more of them available like two and
five so like you could probably get it
all pretty damn quick just
a little more than one and one when i i
kept reading through it multiple times i
was like
is it just one yeah and then one and i'm
like it really is okay
so yeah i'll have to see i'm still very
curious how much they dip their finger
in the money pit when it comes to
transmog i
don't know how much that's gonna cost we
won't know until we get there i know
they're gonna give us some to get
started but if like you run through like
10 tokens that's two armor sets well
what's some set number three
well it's ten bucks or and it's like
then it start that i'll be curious won't
know until we get there so speculation
as
for banshee it's nice to see the fact
that he's got his weapon rotation back
i mean that's your like login every week
and see and there's gonna be twitter
posts like on tuesday
he's selling the bottom dollar with phil
in the blank and people are gonna lose
their mind so i mean that's like
that does give a little more hype to the
weekly rotation especially on
down weeks later in the season we've got
longer seasons probably or so i don't
know how they're gonna handle the future
ones we will be
kind of getting a preview but to know
what that looks like at least there's a
little more for some people to be like
i don't have to grind my ever loving
mind out in gambit if i don't want to at
some point it might fall to him
so we'll see um so those are good to
give gunsmiths a little more
please also bungee i don't
i don't know if anybody listens if this
crosses your ears but i just want to say
can we get rid of like the weapon
telemetry i've heard that multiple
places
yeah yeah what is the point like the
weapon parts alone already are like just
a random role but the weapon telemetry
is a worse currency we don't need to
get rid of it done like how would you
which no it needs to go that's all mine
but yeah i was like
the 801 i got i got a lot of questions i
got to see how 14 looks banshee
not a problem with that just yeah it
seems cool to see some stuff in there i
literally agree with everything you guys
said
uh same thing i love the banshee thing
because it kind of reminds me of
you know the old days with the gunsmith
and the weapon testing but
now you know that's all destiny one
where you the vendors had weight
right and it's like yo there's a hung
jury today that's this that
third you know what i'm saying or
whatever and that that random rotation
so that and
it also helps the new player because the
new player missed out
and he doesn't have any you know decent
role god roll type guns
he's got a chance by logging in we can
say yo grab that whatever
i'm exactly with e on a to though i'm
still
like you just kind of substituted
banshee's role and moving over to ada
and i still feel that that's not enough
of those mods
for a beginning player who has not been
around he's added
such a disadvantage he doesn't have
charged with light stuff he doesn't have
all these
dope builds that are game-changing to
help you with high-end content
warm i sell builds all this stuff so i'm
gonna i love the transmog thing i'll see
you with e we gotta see how that's gonna
go
i wanna see the cost of how much the
shards and all that stuff going to be
with aydah
that's another thing you know we got the
prism discharge and all that
so you know we'll see look half and half
i i love
banshee more than eight it right now
outside of transmog but i do want to
reserve judgment to see how they handle
ada
with those mods but that's where i'm at
but then we got one more thing
e that we got to talk about that uh very
excited to talk about
the the part changes yes yes yeah yeah
we got we got some changes so
for those of you who do nightfalls or
gm's there have been a couple of perks
that are starting to fall and gm's are
starting to see it as well
adept weapons have a possibility of a
perk called
celerity solarity is specific for trials
um this is a powerful perk they said
it's a hundred aim assist handling and
reload plus reduce recoil and spread
but basically the only time it's active
is when you're the last one alive
there's also one for adept weapons seems
to be doing the same thing what is the
thing called uh
bottomless grief um so that's another
one so these are basically when you're
the only person left alive
and a lot of people have an issue with
the fact that
when you get a really high valuable
weapon it's really
kind of frustrating to have one of the
perks be only available if you're in a
crappy situation
it's just not a great feel on top of
this
we got a little more information as to
why
this is a thing and the why
oh my so good i got to figure out
the right paragraph for it but first i
just wanted to see you guys like how do
you feel about those perks and then i
want to find just to get about quick
touch like do you like the perks do you
hate the perks as they stand before this
change what did you think about them
before
about celebrity and volunteering yeah
and then uh bottomless grief did you
like were you just like oh
did you did it ever do anything i know
that cool guys made a video of a
celerity but i was like
most you like what do you guys think
just about the perks i found what i was
looking for
well uh so i do play trial of course i
play trials um
so there's many times where like
i have celebrity on one of my weapons um
and i'm the last one left
it's good i would say it's good
especially when you're playing pvp
or you're playing comp or you're playing
uh you know
trials or i would think they would have
that
especially with gambit but um it's good
um especially when you have weapons of
course it you know boom accuracy
stability and stuff like that last one
handling
it's it's good but it's like okay
it's it's one of those things where it's
just like for
strikes and stuff like that i can't
really
i don't really see it being something
that's like oh man
we it's it's a must-have we gotta have
celery it's one of those things where
i can only see it input pvp specific
type of things it's not really one of
those things with pve because
you can basically pick people up in our
strikes okay he's dead okay they waste
time
yeah and pick him up but in in trials or
you know comp it's situational because
it's like okay
i can get killed right here and peek out
and try to pick him
up or i can go ahead and face these
these two stacks
or three stacks on me right now and then
try to pick up it's situational
and celebrity it works for that basis
but for grand master's bottom appetite i
never got that perk but i got celebrity
but it's just like
it's not really it i just can't see
it being something that is like oh a
must-have thing it's like okay i guess
larry
it helps me out a little bit but it's
not something that's going to give me a
super
advantage over somebody you know yeah
exactly
yeah wouldn't you um look i am going to
sugarcoat it i
discussed it when that perk rolls up on
any gun of mine
i i i just delete it with such fury yeah
it is just look you know i no disrespect
to
chris proctor and all that you know they
saw you know these champion how powerful
it is
the problem is in destiny perk history
any anybody does a video anybody who
really is into
god roles and stuff like that the worst
kind of perks are situational
perks that are so specific though again
the stagnation is the same way i hated
it yeah 90
of the time you will not get the benefit
maybe not who says too high but you know
what i'm saying
okay i was being hard on them but i was
just i got to feel i got to see how i
feel i'm [ __ ] i got to see how i feel
daddy was at a time like you're not even
gonna get to see this thing
like it's just such a and then we're
gonna get into that reasoning
yeah but that's what i'm doing so if you
want me to just open that camera
i'm ready i'm ready i've been holding
this one
uh we intended this to be a great for
clutch last guardian standing plays and
trials specifically when it's active it
is very strong we found a trigger
condition that relies on failure
generally pretty bad
thank you uh and the power grants
doesn't negate
that feeling and the fact that it's also
stealing a perk that you probably want
as well the deep stone [ __ ] origin berks
were well received so
those aren't so i mean they say origin
perks from certain playlists like deep
stone crypt weapons
people like those perks but they're
beneficial all the time so they function
in a different way so that's not hard to
figure out doesn't say only time you can
use this is during the uh
tedx fight yeah you don't see it like i
mean
and that and we'll get into it in a
second but this is why honestly this is
opening a whole can and i was just like
plus when the rainbow's
we introduced the depth weapons of
trials one to try out a new system for
aspirational weapons in a small set
before rolling them out broadly we had
three goals for adept weapons give
players tangible rewards
to aspire give players who've earned
adept weapons a minor power deuce don't
make players who can't earn these
weapons
feel like they can't complete players
who have them again this is an issue
with like having pvp be a thing because
in the other game we're going to talk
about that isn't even an issue it's so
fantastic
so we've seen through suggestions to
make celerity and bottomless grief
intrinsic
only to adapt versions and to touch on
this the idea thematically this is cool
adds flavor to those perks and can give
their sources but there are three
problems
for performance reasons we have a
maximum number of perks that can run on
a character at a time
legendary weapons have a threshold per
number and many of them are
right at the limit adding a perk on top
of that without taking one away causes
bad thing to happen
in the form of random parts of perks
turning off
that's a technical limitation adding a
new perk column
to weapons from specific sources
increases introduces power creep
um
that was that word that they they said
all of a sudden they forgot about
when they when they they got rid of
sunset now that word is back
it's interesting right now remember that
i remember when sunset debuted that word
was the word
now they said we got rid of that because
we do you know you didn't like but
did he go that word again remember
continue
i don't know how high to rate your
pettiness yet we'll see where it gets to
in the end
uh and pretty soon we'd end up having to
do the same with weapons from other
sources
god forbid you have another perk on
there but that's just me adding a new
perk
column to only adept weapons would work
against the third goal of adept weapons
we believe we would feel bad for players
dying to adept that can
they're able to stack celerity with
other things like outlaw and rampage
okay i'm gonna go from the bottom up
because because the last one's the
biggest honestly
so the first one is i want to know what
you guys think of having
perks that only come on adept weapons
whether it be from a gm
or trials do you feel there should be
whether it be intrinsic or otherwise
perks that come
on those for those who are in them okay
i gotta keep it real on this one i gotta
keep it real
because at this point you know i've seen
this now
being in trials going into trials right
the minute you get hit with a depth
messenger
that has a depth perks on it it's over
for you you're
done and these are weapons that not
everybody can get now granted yes
hardcore people are going to work hard
for it they're going to grind for those
things
i respect that but when you have perks
on the debt weapons that's like break
that's already
the weapons are good anyway great stats
and then you add something
extra to it it's just not it's
it's almost toxic at this point because
it it's like okay
the rest of the community are going to
get a chance to even get their hands on
it
i would be fine if they would have did
okay if you did
we're gonna have mods right we're gonna
enhance mods and stuff like that we're
gonna have a depth type of mods
we're gonna put them in the nightfall
strike okay we don't we don't wanna
just put it in grandmaster but we if you
do
legend if you do okay we'll have some
it'll be a
lighter chance of getting them but at
least we're going to have them in the
pool where you can actually
grind and get one instead of okay we're
going to only tell it to the grandmaster
and then the people got it man they're
they're having fun
they're having fun and it's like
everybody else is missing out
on the fun i think that it's just like
okay
it's great um but it's just it's one of
those things that is
it doesn't make any sense um when it
comes to for those things they want us
to grind for weapons but
if only a certain amount of the
community is
getting it and everybody else don't have
access to it it kind of negates the
purpose of it
in my opinion now as with celerity
okay you know i understand um
to a certain said okay yes the perk okay
it's
it's okay but it's not it's not nothing
game breaking
like they're saying right you know but
what
i would have to be honest if you wanted
celerity
it's a mod you can you could actually
put it in an armor
but make that an armor set something
where it's not taking away from the gun
play
and perks that could actually not hinder
you
but actually make you better on the
field
instead of just having something like
that that's just one likes the time
take it out of that make it like almost
like a almost like how
they did with the raid right
the raid perks right you could make
celebrity like
it would actually add more value to the
trials armor
which is a problem that's a great idea
actually
i do like i disagree with your first
part
but i love the second part you see you
you came in very nicely with that
here's my thing and look i feel listen i
want to be fair because what you're
saying
from a balance standpoint is not wrong
i can't disagree with you there this is
my problem now
and now especially with outriders here
is even more apparent now
and the problem is one
when you play this game you want to feel
powerful and you want to have fun
right to your point yes
if the if the weapons have these
advantages
the high-end guys are going to eat
there's no doubt you're not
wrong but where i struggle is if you
don't
give the high-end person something to
chase for
and it's just average he ain't gonna be
playing the game that much longer
and this is the problem that they have
they they
when there was mountaintop and there was
recluse people could hate it all they
want
exactly people were living in comp
people were doing that thing
like when you add these weapons that
have these value
it incentivizes you to play the game
now we're getting situations where it's
like
people the hardcore like myself and we
look to say okay what's the reward we do
grand masters what we get
right and they're like palindrome plus
three
all right it's not you know and again
we're gonna get into outriders
outriders is like yo balls to the wall
you want plus 35 on on this
stat that you like you you like that
skill we're going we're going to put
this boot
with a stack to give you let it recharge
every five seconds like
they're just letting you go free and i
get it
you know but the problem that that this
is where again i got to go back to the
past statement when i was chastising
with power creep you can't have it both
ways
you can't say yo you know
power keeps the thing in order to get
rid of it we gotta sunset your weapons
we're gonna introduce new weapons okay
cool you get us to believe in
that then you don't update enough
weapons in the game
you don't do all this stuff you reneg
you renege now your statement
and now you say we're gonna bring it
back at another time oh no no no nobody
say it excuse me they just say
we're getting rid of sun setting so when
you say you get rid of sunsetting
in theory you're kind of supposed
implying you're getting rid of power
creep and you're going to let us have
fun
right that's kind of what you implying
now now these weapons gonna stay around
now all of a sudden power creeping it
and then we get this and i'm like bro
you can't
do that you you gotta commit whatever it
is
you gotta commit and once you commit you
have to fulfill on the commitment
you have to either if you're sun setting
you have to make sure you have enough
weapons with these new perks
to do it if you're not sun setting and
you're going to let things stay
damn it let us have fun let us have the
the damn plus whatever celerity off the
gun
now the last point i'll say i get the
technical thing and you said it
perfectly bro
if i'm not a dev i'm never going to
disrespect them
if they can't technically add it because
it breaks the weapon
right cool take celerity off
throw it in the bushes on the armor put
it right
on that trial's armor then let's be real
nobody really rocking the armor
anyway and i know eagle love this
because even screaming from the high
heavens
what the hell y'all doing with armor i'm
still waiting for what you clean but
that's awesome and again
it's more apparent the more i play
outriders i'm sitting there looking at
boots that do so much for my abilities
and
just little gloves that's doing all this
stuff and i'm like
damn destiny really kind of need to need
to get with this i mean division was
doing it we've been screaming this for a
long time
armor armor needs to have that road so
phil you're on fire
like that celebrity could be there and
to see them say now
oh we're going to have an alternative
choice and
let's be real y'all in the middle of
trials match are you pausing the game
i'm going to switch over
to celerity what's the teammate get by
the time you load up
and the ui come up you dead before you
can select
take this people you don't have a ton of
time between the rounds
so do you have an ssd do you not you got
the quick switch
right uh so i still got to say this
though
okay go ahead i got it i got to say this
one thing though let's go let's go like
i said to your point
absolutely perfect solid we want to feel
powerful
right we want to we want a chance to
actually feel it outright us we do feel
proud because of
you know what we got going on but one
thing is
okay when we have a deaf weapons right
why not just bring back pentacles
you remember what we was doing back in
forsaken
we had quests that to go to pick up
and go and complete those tests to get
these pinnacle weapons that feel
powerful
that way people who okay you go to comp
right
okay you could stack up a casual guy can
stack up with guys
uh that that are okay they're they're
good they're experiencing pvp
and go get their their quest done so
they can get a revoker so they can get a
recluse
you know what i'm saying what they're
doing with the adept i'd like to say i
get it i understand that the the guys
the guys at the top is going to eat but
when you don't have a
a bounty or a quest to say okay you want
to get this a debt
all right this is what you got to do to
go and get it this is the
requirements it will make it more
meaningful than
okay well we just gonna go and play this
nightfall strike and
and hope for the best guys you know it's
it's just one of those things that's
like okay
you basically taking a depth and saying
okay we're gonna we're gonna go ahead
and bring
a mediocre version of pinnacles back
you know just bring pinnacle back you
already bought desperado back
you can roll that off
did you say oh we're gonna take away
we're gonna take away pinnacles and
we're gonna give you these walmart brain
of
ritual weapons all right go ahead and
have fun
you know it's just those things you know
it's weird yeah yeah i i gotta hit you
on this because i've been i've been
waiting
no i was like so i'm gonna start on just
how the mods function first because i've
gotten into technical and i'll start
opening that can of worms
for the mods themselves like
i can't do without the techno ball get
to the technical a second
from what you guys are saying and then
outriders honestly has me think because
honestly listen to both you guys go back
and forth
the carrot has to be on the stick for
the hardcore has to be there otherwise
what the hell is the point in fighting
through everything to get to the
lighthouse
if it's not there it sucks does it also
suck to be in a control match and not
ever ever in your mind as a solo freebie
player whatever have a chance to see
that
also sucks now if you've been playing a
decent man out writers you know
until you start cranking up world tiers
to crazy levels legendaries don't happen
hardly at all i mean 30 hours in
if there was a point where it was an
extremely low drop
chance and the same thing could go for a
strike playlist to see like
hey i was playing the strikes today and
i got a random adept mod to drop
it would be really really really low
and on the other side at gm say it's
guaranteed like i don't want to go into
gm and not get a drop you better give me
one
if it doesn't drop you better make that
a guarantee so if you are going to be
that person who could go in and grind
hardcore to be like all right cool
knocked out the gm grinded out my mods
awesome or the skilled group
does the person who is a solo player
doesn't have as much skill
can't quite get into a group whatever it
may be can they go into that match made
strike playlist
and at some point probably going to be a
very long time they may see an adept
weapon drop or they may see a mod or
one or the other and they're like i
gotta get something to match up could
they ever get that at some point
tiny minuscule chance wouldn't actually
probably be terrible
to be like okay well this is a thing i
say they get the mud and like well how
what do i put this in
and then they go and look and it gives
them a little deeper depth to it
it's and it's like but if you go and do
a gm or you go and do a trials flawless
that stuff should be 100 guaranteed
i agree so it's like if the if they
could have that balance of you go into
crucible matches or you say comp
comp would be a reason to go get these
weapons it'd be a low chance at the end
of a match to see a drop
but maybe you do get that mod or maybe
you're like oh my god i got an adept
fill in the blank just by playing a comp
match
and maybe the higher rank you get in
comp maybe your your odds go up
a little bit more but trials is the way
to go to the lighthouse guaranteed
right i don't know if that's a perfect
answer either because again they're like
do you do you value it i'm like if they
can play a hundred games of crucible
maybe get a mod and you can go to the
lighthouse in 45 minutes or an hour
and you're still guaranteed it i don't
think they devalued what you do
versus all their crucible matches so
it'd be that like if you give somebody
just the small iota of a chance
it's like a dumb and dumber so you're
telling me there's a chance like
like literally at that point if you can
say that there's a small
chance that it's there and people are
like what are the numbers be like i
don't know i ran 50 strikes and i didn't
get anything i ran 100 and i got like a
mod like it's gonna be a while but there
there would be a chance for somebody to
get there so that's like somewhere
between both of you guys i don't know
it's like the chest has to have
something
whether it's a guarantee and ever the
rest of the world gets a baby chance to
be like what is this a depth messenger
well if you you might have a small
chance to get it same thing with
outriders
you could sit at world tier like three
in story mode and like normal difficulty
and be like
man i don't get that many legendaries
right yeah i'm up here at world tier 14
when i finish the campaign
yeah i haven't had a lot but i was like
i should start seeing more so like
the difficulty should reward much faster
more frequently more consistent that
type of thing
but if you give that other person at
least a tiny chance i think it's for the
better
i think in the long run true what do you
think
before i go technical which is a whole
different worry
you know are you on fire i mean i i
agree i guess my question for ue
specifically because i've been dying to
talk to you about it it was um
you know two quick one how do you feel
about the optional option now that
they're presenting
oh the right the switch perks and then
second
i don't know why this bothered me but i
gotta ask if if this bothers you
like i don't know why that statement
when he goes
we believe you know i said adding a new
perk to column to
only a debt weapons would work against
the third goal of a debt weapons
and we believe would but would feel bad
for players
dying to adapt weapons that are able to
stack celebrity
with things like outlaw and rampage i
don't know why that statement
i mean it's hilarity like what it does
i'm going to read it out again so we can
all be on the same page 100 plus aim
assist handling and reload
right theoretically that doesn't make
you do more damage right you're more
accurate and that so
potentially yeah somebody's going to
have a lot more aim assist to the head
so more bullet magnetism
they're going to be able to swap faster
to it maybe they run out they can reload
quicker
but also in turn they've earned that
right so
i was like no for me it's like you're
asking so it's like for me
like somebody could go into a crucible
match with a basic hand like a one two i
don't even know what the all the 120s
are
like you can go do the same thing with a
120 or a hand can be like oh i got my
140 or 180.
i just got smoked by a steady hand they
can't get that all the time
like and then they do a bottom dollar
well how do i get that 5 000 game
matches and you're like
okay like and those and again but it's
also a skilled player that uses it but
if they have like
an outlaw rampage or rangefinder and
they're like smoking you from across the
map with the bottom dollar
i mean that may as well be an adept perk
in itself now that's again
time dedication and everything else
what's the other time dedication to get
better
seriously you put like like i don't know
if aries is still sitting in chat
i could give him a trash hand cannon he
would beat most people
exactly so it's like there's a point
where skill is going to overwrite the
adept weapon
now granted people are worried that the
low-level player going against the
high-level player with the high skill
weapon
now you're like piling on so it's
his you're right i was like but in this
this situation i'm so
furious is because solarity is
literally you benefiting off of major
disadvantage
your team is dead
right so that means you're going to be
in a 1v2
1v3 situation so at
best you may you know again skill player
gonna be nice regardless
right so at the end of the day i just
feel like why is that why they
so want to defend the celerity guy like
i mean the guy's against the celerity
guy because it's like
that scenario is you listen if you get
cause you're gonna activate if you're
the only one alive and i'm forgetting
that too so if you are in a conference
you're the skilled player and you're
like i could actually clutch it up
but yeah they actually might but it was
like
in turn i was like and if that happens
cool but yes again it's gonna be few and
far between especially on these perks
i'm thinking more like if for future
perks maybe if there's like other stuff
but yeah specifically for these as
they're only for that dying moment
yeah it's like it's not gonna come up
often and in that point the skilled
player might have a chance to use it
the average person may not so i was like
overall
it's it's they are never going to win
all the battles you could ask them and
be like
do we do the casual do we help the
hardcore do we help the middle ground do
they're never going to appease everybody
this one
again it's like i would love to be
around the
you know conference table or on the
whiteboard
i'd be kicked out to me if they can't
have me no but that's like
but again but that's like i would be
very curious to hear the back and forth
to be like
well what about this well what about
this where this is where we settle on
here's the business case for this here's
this like
we need to help out the casual player
because they're a little like they're a
bigger piece of our audience outside of
the hardcore that is like the viking
vocal minority all those things go into
that discussion exactly but again when
it comes to
like the celerity being in that moment
it doesn't feel like it's
specifically these as the last person
live doesn't feel as bad
same thing with an adept weapon for a
night for a nightfall it's even dumber
bottomless grief like if it's not
intrinsic like hey your last person
alive
dude my magazine just doubled i'm still
gone i can fight like
in that moment that's like you should be
extra powerful
trials is a different one but it has the
fact that it's both
the p for bottomless grief kick that
thing on i don't care in pve
you might actually survive a gm in that
crappy moment because you had a couple
more bullets to kill that dude
like why not but see here's the thing
like i said again though
again like i said absolutely making
sense
uh when it comes to why are we why do we
have to
touch celery for something that
like you said you're at a disadvantage
right yeah
for that moment it's good whether you're
a skilled player or not
if you're the last person in trials you
got
and you have two or three people they're
picking up their third dude
yeah chances are you're not gonna
it's a great perk to try to at least
help but
it's listen we play trials a lot
at the end listen you can be skilled but
if you're going up against other skilled
people and it's a man
once the first person get picked and
there's a man advantage they are running
down on you
and it doesn't matter at some point
because the minute the team shot goes
down
i don't care how much extra aim assists
you you're right
you don't say now granted a skill guy
could try to work some things out
so it's like again why penalize
something that is so
situational that is so
nine times out of ten you're still gonna
lose and they're acting like this is the
oh my god we don't want to make the guys
other guys feel so bad that they have
this and i'm like
come on man i'm sorry i i did this one
really
i'm sorry i feel no no we gotta wrap
this one up because we're
horse here we're gonna beat it we beat
it we beat it did you have anything
but last the last thing you know last
thing about it
you know like say it doesn't make any
sense and let's keep it real guys who is
crying about this
i don't see anybody in my group chat i
don't see anybody talking about
man celebrities over power we need to
get rid i don't see anybody saying that
it doesn't make any sense man it doesn't
yeah yeah i know we were beating this so
yeah
we gotta move on no i know i was like we
just got a big show to go through so
gotta play producer man yeah
but the other piece that i wanted to
kind of do and this is the last piece
for the twa but this opens honestly an
interesting discussion that's want to
save a little time
yes for performance reasons
we have a maximum number of perks that
can run on a character at a time
legendary weapons have a threshold per
weapon many of them are
right at the limit adding a perk would
be taking stuff away where literally
park perks stop
working this is honestly
for me that's what you've read about
i remember yeah this is the one that
hurt me more than the other one like you
could be like butt hurt about the other
one like because it's like oh no carrot
like that's fine this one worries me
from a system level
because okay when i think about armor
how many perks can be active at the same
time what about weapons
so they can never add another perk slot
is what they're saying to legendary
weapons wherever you get raids can't get
another perk slot in there
because you're gonna break the game so
what we're seeing now is you get scope
magazine two perks period forever
forever again and that seems like what
we're going to have in destiny 2 and
honestly that
worries me because you have a
potential system of like they said
they're going to rework armor
how many perks can work on not on a
weapon on a character at a time
how many different things can function
is this why set bonuses are not in the
game is this
all of this stuff worries me probably
more than
like the perks like working not working
carried on the end of the stick
those are things for like different
audiences they'll never win that battle
again you could do one be like oh no
why'd you make me mad
oh you helped this one why'd you make us
mad like they're never gonna win but the
the worry of a system level issue
not being able to you know literally one
turns on the other one turns off
that that goes to a deep issue so i know
i obviously threw mine out there i
wanted did this
affect you guys did you think about this
is this an issue to you are you worried
about this for
the next three and a half years of this
game is this anything that like
for you is worrisome are you like are
you okay with the state of things as
they are
uh i i really do
believe that uh we really do need a kind
of a change when it comes to armor set
because if we thinking about it we're
they're introducing different things
every expansion we get right
we're getting we're getting different
mods but the armor
just doesn't feel powerful at all really
it's like
when i take a look at outright it's like
i said that's something that we're going
to get into but
i do take a look at that i was like it's
the polar opposite
yeah it is each armor piece that you get
in out and outriders they have some type
of intrinsic
new type of perk that allows you
that will either better your super sub
class
your weapon play and the way you move
the way destiny has their mods
it's not helping me with wrestling like
granny okay
yeah we got exotic armors cool and they
do different things cool
that's fine but just regular legendary
armors rach
they're not really helping us against
stuff like
okay we're going into grand master
nightfall what's going to help what
armor said is going to help me
get an advantage over these enemies
going going forward when it comes to
grand mass and
saying oh yeah we're good we got
anti-barrier mods that's not
something that's going to give you a
tough armor
where's the where's the the bulletproof
chest set you know something that
is going to give me you know an
advantage like
brazilians okay it's cool that we have
resilience in those
those stats but there's not really no
those aren't even real that
mean that much either i mean resilience
in pvp is a range of like 192 to 202
it's like the tiniest range of pvp and
it's like
can you get two or three if you have
like zero resilience or a couple
whatever the
ask mercury is in the stat guys like
it's a certain number of resilience
threshold you need to hit to not get
like two hit by certain hand cannons
outside of it not much changes there's
couple thresholds for certain weapons so
i'm not saying it's not
in pve i couldn't tell you what
resilience does to save my life
like i never know if like hey do you
have high resilience like you have like
100 or 72
i don't know does it matter it doesn't
feel like i have
a whole lot of damage mitigation or
resistance because my resilience is
higher i still get smoked and this whole
thing of not feeling powerful that's a
different thing
but yeah stats on stats on all this
stuff right now for
armor especially and that's for me was
one of my big worries is because
witch queen has been mentioned at some
point
for what's got to be like an armor 3.0
they said and i'll say this probably way
too many podcasts until i see what it's
going to be
keep saying keep saying i'm going to
keep saying it until i know what the
hell the changes are going to be
and it's one of those that's like i
would say let us put on all exotic gear
apparently outsanity that would break
literally the game break the gate
literally they said like they're already
at the limit right now with one exotic
one exotic weapon and the perks between
those pieces
already break it so
all these little this is that's the
point to where
how much can they do with armor that's
my worry like how much can they really
do with armor if you can't be like
oh man if you have the crucible set you
can go in there and you've got
i don't know you've got an iron banner
set you capture points faster you do i
don't know what the set bonuses are but
apparently none of them
will like we're at the point where they
are going to have to go behind the
system code
to make things have more variety more
options more functions because at this
point it seems like it's a limitation
and that's that's just worrisome for me
so that was just
that was my line i read i didn't want to
like throw it out there because
believe me they're developing this stuff
from home they're trying to build an
expansion from like
apartments and zoom calls and everything
else and what we get is
just like this season they absolutely
knocked it out of the park but for the
long term that's one of those like
deeper worries so that's all i wanted to
bring it up for
the great great point i'll just finish
off what you said you know um i'll be
honest i didn't really think about it
like that
and i remember when you you with me and
you were going into dms you mentioned it
and i was okay you know but that's all
right limitations okay at least they're
giving the reason or whatever whatever
but then if you think about it
you know it's kind of what you say it
you know there's a ceiling
there's a ceiling basically and
basically that letting you know that
you're not going to get
more than that here's the other
frustrating part about it is that
what's included in that ceiling is also
the seasonal mod right and the problem
is
the seasonal mod is is a lot of people
don't know how to utilize it it's not
really explained well
then you have the fact that again you
know
like you just like phil said so
perfectly like
each legendary doesn't
come with its own intrinsic
thing to benefit you in some way right
you're now putting on these mods that
now we know have a limit of what you can
put in
you know what i mean that it it now it's
like okay it worried yeah it does it
does
i'm not gonna say i'm worried i'm only
worried from the standpoint of how long
we are staying with this current
iteration
of destiny right this engine
no disrespect it's great the gun plays
great we have
amazing spots high boxes it looks great
we know that
but from me and ue have always preached
at some point
you're going to hit ceiling we've
already seen oh content vote move we're
going to move this we got to conserve
space right
now we're hearing this so at what point
you know is it is something that they
can upgrade on the fly to get past this
limitation
and do an in game upgrade so to speak
or is it what we think you need to make
destiny 3.
yeah prescott's saying the same thing in
chat he's like d2 is working on an old
engine
you can patch you could put other stuff
on you can take stuff out of the game
you can polish it up for the new one
but still the the the dna of this game
is based in something that is going to
be really hard for them to move and
change
they can't just be like hey ue5 when it
comes out switch it over
right because yeah i was like no let's
just go
you're looking no i was just gonna say
like ue5 like
part of i think their fear of that and
we've said it before
is their gun play they have it working
in this engine
and i know they're afraid to lose that
right and
until their defense yeah like we don't
without the i'm playing destiny it's not
destiny let's just call it
the best i'm playing game i don't care
nobody says i don't care what i write
this is good don't know despite alright
i mean it just it is what it is when it
comes to gun play
shooting someone the way it feel by far
but
we know what who the champ is the thing
just comes down to we can't
yeah i don't want them to lose what
makes them that's the at the best of it
but we also have to keep in mind that
this game is supported on what ps
three still or this is for four
ps4 still right and now it's ps5
whatever
so we still have that lowest common
denominator
that they always got a support for with
this
engine and at some point you know
you you're reaching the ceiling like me
and you said you're gonna have to make
that cut off if you want to really
evolve this game to the next level yeah
that's why
again last point i love competition when
comedy is good when you see
something like an outright or something
like that that are now introducing these
things and as destiny plays we go
yeah we kind of need that you know what
i said it is like
hmm you know what i'm saying and that's
where i
love competition and that that's just
what i was going to get into
you're only as good you're only as good
as your
your lowest console and like i said
i'm still i'm still in the middle of
trying to attract give me a ps5
as well but that being said
it's probably going to take them cutting
off
xbox one and playstation 4
for them just continuing it just like
they did back in rise of mine you
remember
at rise you couldn't get that expansion
of ps3
and xbox 360. you had to go to ps4
to get that experience so i think that's
what it's probably going to take
i don't know it could be lifo they could
say hey my fault that's
it for for a ps4 xbox one okay you guys
are thinking it's post lightfall post
season 10 i think that's your d3 and i
think they're gonna milk the
large console base on this one
unfortunately for a while
and that's why it's just a bigger word
for me is because you have that 160 70
however many xbox plus playstation
you know whatever that number is that's
too many people for them to
shop their own legs out from underneath
them when it comes to selling what if
they went with queen
right now that would hurt them at all
so then you're like okay is it going to
be light fallen it's like maybe there
will be more out there maybe the economy
is better but again where do you draw
the line where you want to make that
system
as they have this light and dark saga
and even sony you know they want to do
the generations
like you know they've changed the entire
framework of what they wanted to do and
they're like they're going to be
supporting
you know these things for longer some
things are going to be exclusively built
for the new stuff because
you haven't had it before right and they
can do that but again if this is a live
service
you can't just be like well you can't
get witch queen you can't see the end of
the story because you have an old
console
at least right now they can't and again
i don't know where they draw that line
so it's it's tough um they can do it
it's just a matter of like you said
player base everything you said and
right now there's still not enough ps5s
and and series x's in the wild from a
business standpoint they they can't do
it right now so i agree
continue i know we gotta move on yeah um
final thing that's pretty much it
because we do
uh just a reminder to you guys if you
are listening to this uh the presage
exotic mission deep dive that will be
wednesday it's going to be basically a
daily reset time so 10 a.m pacific
daylight time
um you can watch on twitch you can watch
on youtube they'll be doing the deep
dive
those are always amazing if you haven't
watched any of the deep dives there was
they did one on deep stone crypt you'll
learn a lot
concept art just hearing what the devs
go through the cycles you can see like
what the
what prophecy i think it was like you
could see it was like a sliding thing
but
you can see what it was at one point and
then just to see the concepts are cool
so
other than that basic stuff um you know
weekly issues
all that basic stuff is there but at
this point what i do want to do is
switch it over
to outriders you so
for all of us that have played it um
some are farther than others but we've
all played a different amount of time in
there before i go into mine
i just want to see where you are you
guys at and again depending on who's
listening who hasn't even picked it up
yet who may be on the fence
where how far do you guys feel you're in
the game you guys could probably tell me
like a biome that you're in and i can
tell you but
where do you guys think you're out so
far and
high level and then i'm going to start
deep
diving deeper and deeper phil
well so i did i got a chance of like i
said friday
i got a chance to jump in um and play it
um like i said right now i'm at i'm
level
with eight i'm level eight right now so
i'm still young in the game
but um so far man i'm really loving
um not only you know just the scenery of
the game but the the
feel it kind of gives me that um you
know how mass effect play right
yeah the match face third person yeah
you know
you can kind of get that feel good
comparison yep very good
so for me that's something that's like
oh yeah
uh um and that drew me in right then and
then the sub classes
finally getting the subclasses one i'm
only trickster i love that okay
that's that being able to just like
teleport behind people
like they're sitting there shooting like
oh where'd he go pop
you're dead i love the feel of the game
and then the loot
from the loop like i said the loot is
wonderful man
the stats that they have on it that
actually can really amplify
your subclass i love that
armor solid the guns i like the guns too
they don't feel like destiny but they're
i mean they're good
yeah they're really good i really i
really enjoy that and
the story and where they're taking the
story you know you're waking up you're
kind of like
it's kind of like a captain america
thing like where okay
you know you're waking up you know
what i gotta get myself
what's your what's your high level
what's your high level world right now
where are you at
i think i'm like a level 14 i think i'm
like
or old tier six or seven or something
um played it with two friends um
who are ahead of me one thing i like is
that quality
let's just this is the main theme i like
quality
of life awesome outstanding
outstanding they've thought of a lot of
um things that
really when i'm playing with people who
are higher level that came to play with
me
they were still benefiting the world
tier system is really cool because i
like how that scales up and down
that part is dope you know i found my my
legs with
techno techno really spoke to me and it
was crazy in games i'm never really
a guy that picks like a sniper class so
to speak i started specking my builds
towards sniper weapons and power you
went up top
yeah i went top but i went a little bit
on bottom for a couple of skills that i
liked
you know what i'm saying sorry i'm like
a mix i can honestly tell you you won't
want to do that
okay you know i'm learning the main
reason
um you have 20 total skill points to get
to the end of one of the trees you're
going to use
the whole thing you can usually get like
deep into the tree maybe one or two of
the offshoots that you might have like
two or three to like grab a little extra
health or a little extra nominee power
but your focus is beneficial usually in
that final one a couple years
you told me i didn't know that but again
this is the beauty of outright is what
you're just saying
this is the first game i have seen and i
played a lot of skill blaze games
where you can reset without penalty
uh i know exactly unlike a game that we
love
with an artifact that we have that
certain glimmering prices keep doubling
and tripling
and you can't even unlock it all because
they're already limited in that slot it
costs
energy you can't over they made sure you
can't overdo it anyway
yes what i really like
something is simple i don't think about
being kai batu because
we always go at it yeah he's my he's my
ui
quality life connoisseur and when
destiny does something stupid i have to
hear about this
for hours about how this is terrible and
what the hell bungie
and playing outriders for now you know
two days
whatever's been i have to admit
there is something refreshing about
hitting
mark on all the whites in the blink
delete all there is something refreshing
about
killing enemies on the battlefield and
having my thing specked where all i got
to do is press down on the d-pad and i
don't even have to go to loot the loo
comes to me oh my gosh
amazing like the theme with listen
i it still has its flaws minor picks
that are like this
i i i i'm not that much of a fan of the
story
i think the story's stupid but that's
just me you know however
my line game saved me because i got to a
certain section
where it was hilarious what happened and
the game didn't even take itself
seriously so i said okay you know what
you're not taking it seriously i'm not
going to take it as seriously
i'm going to bring my levels down on the
story and just have fun because the
gameplay that the moment-to-moment game
play
is super refreshing and the last point
is um
i think you nailed it man like now i got
the appreciation of why
he feels so crazy the way he does about
armor
because i'm sitting there every
encounter
right stop all right let's see what we
got and go
oh these boots do that with this skill
oh i could do it did you just start
having these
fun concoctions and you can't wait and
then the addiction starts and you're
like yo
this is so [ __ ] fun and then it's
like you got the
the like sorry language
i was like i was having fun i got to
love it i love it
is it the weapons of the the the techno
one that gives you the one that give you
the terminator one but
destruction and then i get tools
instructions like that and i'm
like yo okay and i'm just i'm i'm
figuring out
bills and then i'm stacking toxic
weapons with this and
there's just a lot of concoctions listen
is that
is does the game have some flaws yeah
absolutely for everything
god damn you want to go over that bridge
you got a load jump over the bridge
yeah you're going to want an ssd for
this game oh god you got
ssd you want to yeah you got to do all
this extra stuff and i get it look
they're working out the kings for
certain things
you know um i will say this though
my main complaint at first also was
graphics
right and i was like oh graphic models i
don't know about them facebook
looking very ps3-ish with your hair your
hair like a ps3
but when it comes to the world once i
got out of the initial camp
yep which was possible everything was
brown i'm like
you know just it didn't look pretty
honestly the demo doesn't do it justice
right now when you get the car and you
go out
in the world that's right and i see
and you look at the car and you're out
in the field it's beautiful
when you get to the snow park oh and
then the thing i like and this is the
this is the ultimate indictment on
division
this is where outright is is really
going to smack division sorry division
levels i got to get you
the prior division is shooting to do
with the hoodie 50 times
right it doesn't feel see where they got
is they got the destiny with the
monsters
and they got the big beefy guys the ai
of the enemy guys
oh okay if you are looking near a melee
guy tuck and roll
like yes those male guys are legit
especially
with fear as squishy and as squishy as
my build is
yeah i'm terrified of them oh god am i
ever
bro it was it and and the thing that
destiny does
well that they've learned is destiny has
great boss and kind of
you know they we we have our issues with
the way they they you know power gate
some of the damage checks some of us now
we know that
but what makes a luna shooter fun is
when you're fighting like that big
you know spot like these impossible
larger-than-life things
that's what division can't do right it's
still
captain sanchez with a regular
bulletproof vest
you know i'm saying you're it's no
epicness to that you know what i'm
saying yeah like i'm
in that cave with all the spider demons
and then that big
caterpillar came out the thing and i'm
it was epic i'm like this
is what i'm talking about i ain't gonna
lie
ain't gonna lie i gotta say it now so
you're here oh you're fine
the foundation is strong
yeah dusty better pay attention i i've
never said this in a while i'm just
gonna say this
never i'm never in my mom's gonna say
destiny kill we ain't doing that we we
know destiny is destiny and they gonna
do what they got to do
but they're gonna be pushed if this
company does
stays on course stays with the updates
does what they have to do
they've got the basic game play down
they've got the
the system down and they look like they
could they look like they got a lot of
legs man i mean
i was very i cannot believe i was liking
it
you remember how hard i was on in my
first adventure i know absolutely yeah
so like
i cannot believe how much fun
i can't wait to get off this podcast go
back like that's where i'm at i'm like
he's like yo phil you got to hurry up
what you're talking because i got to get
i already know
the face i seen the fake because i know
the face i know eat that's my brother
i'm like yo i want to get back to play
that's how much fun and the last thing
i'll say is oh the cocktail remember
this is a leadership square
second yeah no doubt yeah
obviously like but again like shout out
to people can fly
yes they have learned the lessons they
did the research
they didn't try to put themselves in
live service they put themselves in this
nice box
and here's another thing like cross play
was there
you know had some nice testing with that
ps5 and xbox series x
we were playing normally pc they got to
work out the kinks we know they got to
work out the live service
it's their first week yeah i got to cut
them slack all lunar shooters
have this service stuff in the first
week let's let it settle but look
foundation wise e i go front i said he
just happened i i really thought she was
captain i was like
he he the ambassador they square enix
they gave him a robe he's playing they
got him you know they got my boy
i'm joking you know i know they didn't
do that to you but the reality is i
thought maybe he's just so excited for
it
and it's really not because the game is
that good as it is and
uh nah nah nah i played but now it's
it's
i'm having a ton of fun i mean yeah yeah
it's it's it and
that destiny we're going to we got it we
got to talk we gotta we we have
someone is here so they say the anthem
and this ain't division it's on it's on
yeah we got to see man salute to them
is it's a fun game y'all it is really i
did not think i would be saying this on
this podcast today
like yo he was right this this thing i
thought
i thought you were being too hard and
then when i got the gear and i got the
loop
i'm like yo he's right this is so much
fun oh last point last point
exotics yes there's another legendaries
in this one
true i never thought and this was
division
i'm sorry the exotics it's a regular gun
with it with a gold
logo you know anything the combo you
know what i'm saying like
yeah it's still a shotgun and it's still
right it's a shotgun
and that's it these weapons have you
seen paul tassie's twitter
have you seen your like these look like
exotic
weapons like it's the first time i've
seen
never go i'm never gonna disrespect god
but like bungie's god tear when it comes
to exotics and design
we know that but it's the first game
that i'm like oh
i mean bunches here but oh y'all at
least got something that's
worth grinding that looks cool that
listen close enough exactly yeah
that good dope man yeah close enough
they not but but yo
and if you do enough things right yeah
but yeah i'll let you go back because i
mean y'all
you know because i'm curious you've been
blazing but yeah
i bet they need to eat that you was
right man i i i didn't think i would
have this fun i didn't
take them as seriously and this is a
good game this is a great foundation
it's really exciting to play
i'm afraid to say anything because i
don't know when i'm gonna stop
because i don't know what i'm gonna stop
talking
um so last night
i rolled the credits i rolled the
credits
at world tier 14 level 30.
oh you was having fun
and i can tell you
i enjoyed the whole journey but i think
like the build that i made for my
character
oh man um
it's where you're headed but it's so
specialized into i am a one-trick pony
without a question and i can know that
from the final boss fight
uh so basically yeah somebody in chat
asked how many hours for the story so
i'll explain the way i paid
played through they explained it as a
hub and spoke system so you have a hub
each little place your park trucks truck
parks
where are your truck parks and then
you've got like a little area you can
explore
you'll have a main story piece of that
area
and then you can get back to the truck
and be like hey we want to go on to the
next thing you can totally do that
or in that area there's usually a couple
other side quests from
your characters a couple other things
you can couple over side quests
so usually what i would do is each
little hub i would do the main quest get
back to the camp and then be like all
right
one or two more side quests knock those
out cool got that done
everything looks clean i've seen most of
the area move on to the next one
now when you get to a certain point you
unlock things called hunts and also
uh targets those actually unlock
basically everywhere as you go through
so there's stuff i could go back and do
that i have not done
so there's still stuff i haven't
actually like certain fights that i
haven't done but i've seen
every zone um so that's the way i went
through it i rolled credits
if you took the normal demo playthrough
probably
um and again i went from the demo world
tier five and up so i had a little bit
of a leg up probably on world tier
um but it was about probably 30 hours
okay so that's where like and that was
like
zone probably two side quests and go it
wasn't like
everything go back and do all every
single hunt back
couple side quests that were available
two or three whatever and then go
now i will tell you guys don't skip your
side quests on some of these things when
you get towards the end amazing
there is well i'll tell you there's one
side quest that gives you a choice of
three legendaries and these are the top
dogs so
one of those later on towards the end
don't skip it
i can promise you don't skip it because
there's some cool stuff in there and it
was a tough call to make but
the way my place that was it was an
obvious choice um
the story along the way i haven't played
mass effect so i can't compare to that
obviously
for a cool sci-fi story i like the
journey that it went through
um when you get to the end
i'm feeling for some of these characters
take the minute or two and talk to some
of these people
please talk to your npcs like you're
like
kind of like you know brush the dirt off
your shoulder
you know kind of empty vessel hero guy
he has his moments and stuff
like there's also a couple moments when
it's just like
holy crap they actually did that they're
like
we're gonna go there oh they went there
like there's a couple of those
and that's especially where some of the
side quests come in as well and i was
just like
there's one i can't spoil when you get
there but even chat when they were
watching it were just like
are we yep we did so there are some
moments where you're just like
they it is like there's some bad
language in it
there's some moments that it it's one of
those for stories do some of the side
quests talk to the other characters
there's just a couple moments and you're
like oh this is that type of world
so that's why i was like the side quests
are part of the journey and honestly if
you go back to do them later it's going
to feel a little weird
so that's why i did like the couple each
zone side quests
to kind of get them in context if i go
back to like i'm at the end and if i go
back to the snowy place and i do it i'd
be like probably doesn't have the same
feel
right so that's my advice now some
people are just like i don't care about
the story i just want to do the loot and
that's fine
um but the side quests be rewarding
that's the other thing is like
you can the way the world tier works and
this is one of like my first tips in a
video the world's here you can always
dumb it down
you can always lower that world tier
down any time you want to your goal is
to continually
unlock it because it allows you to wear
higher and higher gear if a boss fight
is kicking her butt you can
bump it like 10 levels down to story
mode kill the boss
go back on your way and if you get like
a decent you could totally do that
and you might miss out on what have you
ever done that nope
yeah because you left it right get you i
left it auto and it's an auto thing you
could honestly
play through the whole thing on story
which is everything is two levels below
you play through the entire campaign and
you'd still see it all
question did you ever because from my
understanding the way the world tier
works is it kind of
assesses you as you go so have you ever
been in a situation where you were
getting
like you're behind whip and they were
like yo will you think about going back
down
ever did it ever happen to you because i
heard that could happen in the game
oh it can yeah okay i mean i was like
but i just had to ask no no there were a
couple times i was like dude i'm getting
my butt royally kicked right now like
okay and it's also the way my build is
set up i'm kind of squishy but i'm also
ultra power i'm a glass cannon the way
i'm currently i'll get you
um so it's part of my build but i was
like if i can get this down i know i'm
pumping out a lot of damage i just gotta
you know get a better dodge learn the
moves a little bit more and you know a
little bit of dark souls like the
some of the fights are like a little
crazy there were some boss glitches some
of the moves i'm not like
it's not perfect by any means but
i didn't turn it down because i liked
the challenge and i was able to overcome
it now
i do want to go play the other classes
and see how they feel in the same way
because i'm very curious of certain
builds now there's all so many mods
you're probably going to be able to make
some successful but i'm just still very
curious because
my i put out so much
damage but i'm pretty i'm like i'm
pretty squishy if two or three things
surround me and one guy jumps at me i
can die pretty fast
but i'm also able to keep a lot of
things at bay because
i'll tell you guys when i make this
video it's an infinite ammo just
absolute monster crit build
i don't have to reload over
jesus so it's and
and honestly it's my crits like a normal
shot might do like five thousand
a crit and then the second crit i've hit
100k
shots so yeah
100k on a bullet that's a sniper rifle
but i've hit 100k on a bullet
light machine gun 15k a bullet
so but also like i'm pretty squishy so
like
that's it's but that's why
for me i love that in any good rpg
you can choose to be the glass cannon is
it hard to solo stuff yes
uh the nice thing about the technomancer
the leeching is helping which is what
plays into this so well
so i'm really curious how the other
classes play um
but for me it's like i can tell you the
challenge was just about perfect the
whole way for me
because like i got up when i finished
that world tier 14
i literally beat the final boss and
dinged level 30. i was like that was
kind of perfect
so it was like i had a little bit of a
jump up because i went from the
main level at you know level seven then
went from there so if you'd probably be
a little behind
but the only difference is you might
have to play a little bit more to level
it up
so because like i you know in the demo
you might not get to level seven world
tier five
you know if you play through the normal
first area you probably won't be there
so then you i might recommend going to
do some other side quests um got a
couple couple questions for you
absolutely
yeah yeah um i'm sorry i wasn't gonna
shut up so
no no i love this i love this this is
this is great that's what we're here for
um the thing is okay so now that you've
done the 30 i mean whatever you got the
you know thing
now you said they were expeditions or
something or
literally you beat it and then more
opens up
wow okay now is the more now here's the
is the magic question because i know
we're in the
the honeymoon phase right and this is
where
a lot of the destiny killers not that
outrageous came out they said they were
their own lane
they're not trying to hit the live
service route so they claim you know
this is different right so
my question is is the expeditions
more of the same is it unique content or
is it like do this content over with
these modifiers or
kind of thing like what is it so to
speak so an expedition i've done a
couple
um basically kind of start like
challenge tier five if you want to
the idea is they're timed okay so first
it's a timed thing
you can choose your difficulty level
higher the difficulty level
higher the chances at certain x you know
rarity of drops how that's going to work
uh so i opened up world t or challenge
tier eight
challenger 15 is like literally level 50
so it's gonna kick your ass
um challenge tier eight i don't remember
the enemies i was fighting it might be
like 40 41 42 somewhere in there
legendary drop chance 2.5 percent so
it's not bad now i will tell you
there is another currency that comes in
when you get to expeditions that you
haven't seen yet
okay those are what you can do to buy
crazy stuff you've seen tier
you've seen epic armor you haven't seen
legendary armor yet
you won't until you get to expeditions
tier three mods on armor are the game
changers for how you're gonna play
right so it's so it's a time of activity
and the main thing is the exit the
challenge level sets up just the way the
world's tier do
enemies are a higher difficulty so
they're a higher level you know more
damage to you
more health that type of stuff um but
again the loot will drop higher
right so it's all about like that level
of loot getting that optimized build
that type of thing okay um somebody said
it's a borderland styling game i didn't
do as much on the end game
for borderlands i didn't hardly play
that much at all but it is going to be
to a point to where
you will not play this forever right
yeah that's that was
like that's it's a lot it's not a live
service they're not going to always be
like well here's a new level here's
anything to go for here's the new
expedition
there is an end expedition you're going
for it's going to take you a while to
get there
but there's a final expedition that is
going to be the finale
and the grind is going to be like how
much you want to replay these how much
you want to
go in i mean the timer for gold rewards
on one of them was like 13 minutes
i was actually able to innate my build
is a little crazy but i also died one
more time trying to do that so
it is that point to where
it's only going to last some people so
long they may play through the campaign
they may try some of the expeditions
right it may not get be the end game
thing
for them but i still think the journey
just before you even get to the
expeditions is worth it anyway
yeah i'm just like you got a question
so e so do you see can
do you actually see them actually saying
okay guys
you know we stuck around we're gonna
have this expansion right
we're gonna make an expansion for the
game um
but this time we're gonna add raids to
it
can do you see a potential for that
or is it like no everybody always wants
a raid and this is not a game for that
okay that's not what this game is going
to be about it's not as much about
mechanics or anything else this is the
best way to describe it it's diablo
it's a third person diablo shock blow
that's the five i mean that's
i've seen community managers mention it
i've got literally talking points as an
ambassador
it is i mean because then you're doing
like teamwork communication mechanics
boss fights and stuff like that
this is a you know basically the
expeditions are going to be your paragon
levels are going to be
that type of thing for a diablo for
those who love it
you are going to be able to optimize to
like the
nth degree but in an expansion i could
see them add more
story content i could see them at higher
world tiers i could see them add more
expeditions
however they do the expansion or just
honestly in outriders too
prequel i don't know how they do in out
writers too i'd be very curious honestly
having seen the story
um i want one i can tell you it's like i
hope they get all the support they need
and i think the success of the servers
and the size and stuff like that
but no this is comparing it to destiny
is not
not doing it justice that's not what it
is
yeah and to ask for raid mechanics or
anything of that nature that's not what
this game is about so
that one you're talking about community
team like team mechanics working
together to shoot this ball so i can
shoot this eye on the other side of the
room
no this is how min maxed and optimized
can you make your character can you work
together and survive now i can tell you
team synergy of like
there are perks that you could do if you
have like hey i've got this like
pyromancer with me we need to be
setting everything on fire burning
damage because their setup is so crazy
because they can just
roast everything that's burning like
there are gonna be builds that are good
for solo and there are going to be
builds for a team
that are going to be so specialized
there's certain perks that work for
teams
yeah like your tank guy for a team build
gonna be completely different than a
solo tank build
so all of that's there and there's some
there's some cool ways to play together
but it is not going to get to the
mechanics of your base that's not what
it's for
it's truly it's a diablo paragon level
grind 100
yeah i agree and um you know i think
what
doesn't get enough credit that some
people don't talk about
is the unique aspect of killing things
with your abilities
to leech health and stay alive like that
is a unique
thing you know i'm saying it it
fundamentally changes the way you play
the game
yeah because most cover shooters you
know you got to hide you got to stay
hide get
safe whatever whatever covers who knows
yeah yeah
you use your bedpack or whatever this is
like no
if you engaged i was coming up with
bills i was like
i'm continually doing dps but i'm
getting my health back with this ability
so that i'm keeping my so it changed i
was like why am i hiding all the time
i'll stop playing it like it's gears of
war i was like don't run out there and
go
get what you got to get you know cause
um i think tassie said it like
i had to stop playing it like a
traditional cover shooter but uh
like especially two of the classes it's
very much not but even now
i'm literally standing in the open the
entire time yeah for the most part
exactly and the other thing i noticed is
when i was fighting like
those captains or something but i like
how like
certain abilities i was doing is like no
no he resistant to that
do you know why he's resistant i don't
know so you can explain to me so
lord basically they build up a
resistance if you use abilities over and
over and over
really so there's an icon that looks
almost like the recycle triple aero
thing yeah
that little icon when it hits a point of
you've triggered it you're not gonna
affect them with that ability until that
cooldown is done
so if you so you see their bar charge
you see they're like hey i'm gonna do
this ability
certain classes have interrupts and it
literally says in the skill tree
you can stop that ability now granted on
the other side
if i just hit some guy with like four
shrapnel bombs
which is one of the technomancer's
abilities if i hit him four times
he's gonna have a resistance that then
he's gonna be able to cast it and not be
interrupted because i overabused it
so it's planning and how to use your
interrupts on certain big
enemies uh to make sure you save the
interrupt for the right time
did not know that i didn't know that i'm
spamming the abilities actually is to
your detriment
i i didn't i didn't like yeah there's
certain ones you can
certain ones you can't but your
interrupts specifically those are ones
and maybe they're just like resistant to
your type of abilities like
right i mean but that thing but that's
but this is another thing about my build
i'm not even worried about that it
doesn't matter
that's how stupidly powerful i am but
that's again why i really want to play
another class and i'm going to go
devastator
just to be the polar opposite of mine
just to feel it different
um but there
there are the auto loot is amazing
you that's like basically the way i
alert loot says like you can hit a
button
if you die if you leave the area it's
going to pick up everything you dropped
at a certain level if you don't want to
see a blue ever again in your life which
i'm probably at that point
now unless i just want to sell it for
scrap by the way um sell your stuff for
scrap and build it up that's a good idea
but that's a whole hole yeah i've got it
i have a couple videos i want to make i
just don't know what order to put them
out in
um but when you go into
the auto loot you're like i only want to
see purples it's all you're ever gonna
see
your inventory is not going to fill up
with blues anymore you're only going to
get the purples and you can choose to
never see a blue in your inventory ever
again
destiny come on yeah get on that night
it's kind of nice isn't it
i know i know the feeling the mark all
the first time i clicked that i was like
holy
crap oh my god it was amazing i was like
this is amazing
i lost it i was so enamored with that i
was like
it's the greatest like yeah yeah but
listen i agree i think
you nailed all the points i think it's
um it's not trying to be destiny
it's definitely more diablo definitely a
little more borderland stuff but
it just you know it they got a lot of
potential a foundation and whether it be
i'm with you feel like i don't know if
they're gonna do listen if they even
thought about doing the end game stuff
with ray that didn't know
we now we really talking in trouble but
i don't think they're trying to do that
i think what he said is right i think
they know what they are and if they are
content to bring out expansions with
more story content or more levels and
stuff like that
you add a fifth class yeah or something
that's one of those we get people to
play it all over again
exactly and it it as long as they keep
doing that and
i am perfectly fine to play this during
those you know
down times of of investing whatever and
i would i did not miss destiny this week
i would say that i was
okay i'm here i've had fun i'm doing
this and yeah
yeah i was just like okay you know now
the good thing is this we we know
one thing i love about bungie is
they're great when they're up against
the wall
and i'm not saying they're completely
they they
their history has shown me this whenever
the new hotness comes out to challenge
them
they actually fall back during the week
at first and let the other
see what they do this is getting a lot
of positive feedback
right so hopefully you know i'm saying
this now accelerates
some things that we've been asking for
you know i mean and things that we need
and again competition is good
competition is good man and um
oh yeah shout out to hunter he said he
said he found out right it's a mix of
destiny
gears of war and final fantasy
interesting with the square there yeah
and
they did a lot of things right man for
me what really impressed me is how fun
it is cooperatively with a group
how fun the encounters are with enemy ai
detention the the different mechanics
sometimes those snipers are pasha you
got to be careful
yeah you know what i mean and the last
thing that really impressed me i'm very
a stickler with this
and this is what division didn't do for
me again the boss encounters i really
feel their epicness to it there's a
there's a grandiose okay we gotta fight
this big thing
and when you have that in your game
because that's what destiny has
now you got a formula so yeah the sky's
the limit they just gotta
you know stick with it bring out good
content keep up with it and if they take
little breaks before the next expansion
fine but
this is a great this is a great space
they found their pocket
i was like you say take breaks they're
going to make sure it runs
they're not going to be adding anything
to the game for quite a while don't
expect any additional content anything
like that it
what you get the complete package okay
so that's one of those things just to be
clear to everybody just because that's
one thing people are like well when's
the next season
you get the whole thing when you buy it
there's no
rushing in there's no extra stuff
there's no hey did i catch the season
nothing is like that is gonna come
there's no live service planned period
doesn't say things are not coming in the
future but there is no calendar plan or
otherwise
they just want to make sure this thing
launches and runs well right launch is
big
servers are finally getting back to a
decent point uh they had some issues
with that
but like nothing zero is on the books so
what you buy is what you get until they
say otherwise
so i'm just trying to be clear on that
one you're setting realistic
expectations
yeah i'm saying that that's yeah and and
hey you know
it borderline kind of borderline
borderlands kind of does that where it's
like okay
you're here you blaze this content you
do everything that you can do
and then you're done and then when they
decide to come out with something else
then
you do it you get you get to it but i'm
fine with it
it's a nice alternative it fits my
schedule so i'm okay i'm biased
yes hey fine by me i could not i could
juggle both with that type of
uh cadence you know what i mean if you
knock on live service be great okay i
got this other thing again
i can do play other stuff so yeah yeah i
think that's the good thing about it is
you there's no rush it that's why i said
enjoy the side quest there there
some people aren't gonna pick one class
and i will say if a class doesn't
meld with you fairly early some of the
skill trees i think are going to be deep
that's why i was like i need to get into
the other classes or at least one other
one to see how these things feel
um some of these are going to take some
time to build up
to get into you know their stride
putting mods together
having these things all work together
and it took a while for me like
the technomancer for a solo player is
probably not a bad way to go
because your healing is based on
unleaching basically the damage you're
doing is healing you and that's like a
continuous thing
does help with boss fights as well when
it comes to other classes there are some
abilities that can like
suck you know health or armor other
things from shields whatever
but the pure heel is only the
technomancer
so it is one of those better solo pieces
so if you are
curious about that you like the typical
third-person shooter you like the idea
of like
continuously getting some damage back
you get like you know 10
8 12 what is it uh i can't remember it's
like 10 15 percent
of your damage you do so it's not the
fastest
as like most of the other classes when
you kill one enemy you get 24
of your health so if you kill like two
or three enemies your health is full but
if you're taking damage it's hard to
continuously have that cycle
that's why my build works for me and
that's why i'm very curious to see how
much health does the other classes have
because i know
literally like if i play a tank
devastator
they literally gonna have the most
health the most armor the most damage
mitigation to survive
some crazy chunks of stuff that happens
so
yeah last question for you um what's
like the craziest
exotic you've got that you like yo this
is i like that this is crazy
or you know gun or whatever i've only
had three legendaries
i haven't had a bunch um i got one of
the ones from the demo i've had a couple
times so i've been slightly unlucky
there
uh it was the machine gun that i got in
the end
uh that actually let me beat the boss
and it was literally i had like the
world tier awards like 12 13 14 15 are
legendary weapons so like you pick
just you're gonna get a legendary you're
gonna get one guarantee i literally got
a light machine gun
and i couldn't go back and change a mod
out i pulled the light machine gun
and that's actually what let me beat the
game it was hilarious
because like i was very set up on a
build and it was working and i was
getting
close on damage but if i like i missed
wrong and it's yeah i don't want to
spoil anything but if like if something
didn't quite work out
and i was like i want to switch one
thing over but it's not quite and it's
like
and then i got this one and it worked
out well enough that i was able to make
it happen
um hold on i have a picture of a
couple just because i know i knew i was
going to kind of look at stuff so i just
wanted to like
um so there's a couple options too
and some of these just sound crazy so
some of these are level 45 and i can't
even buy them yet
so i'll spoil a little bit but for a 45
weapon which is not the cap by the way
so one's called the juggler it's an
assault rifle
uh and it's a tier three mod the first
shot after reloading becomes an anomaly
projectile
dealing 76 000 damage in a 5 meter
radius
so somebody basically described it as
after you reload your first projectile
basically becomes a mountaintop shot
that's like i was like that's not bad
uh so and this is like these this is the
vendor i got to when i was like when you
start doing some of these crazy things
um you're able to
like the expeditions build a currency i
could buy some of these if i build up
enough expedition currency but there's
only like three or four in his rotation
so they don't come up that often
another one and this is specifically
where builds come in so there's like ash
and bullets
you can shoot an enemy and turn them
into ash and they like freeze in place
it's one you may see at a low level
ultimate action bullets can happen every
second
oh wow and what you can do as a pyramid
and this is where like
when you fall into the rabbit hole of a
build it gets a little insane
so i'll just take this one for example
the way a pyromancer
works is if you do fire if you do a
skill damage to an enemy you mark them
when they're marked if they die you get
healed that's how you'll stay alive
there's a mod somewhere on one of the
armor mods that can take
your ability and then you have a so when
you mark them
or sorry multiple things that's how you
get health
then a lot of the pyromancers fire so
you're burning a lot of enemies with
most of the things you do
when anything is burning there you have
one ability called overheat
basically it's like picture overheating
it's like they're alive and you're like
over cooking you fret you basically just
like incinerate them
you do a crazy boost in damage and you
can do that to a
huge like almost a whole combat arena it
doesn't have much of a range
normally that will like consume the burn
debuff
and then that will cause like the 10 20
x crazy damage number you're gonna get
so take this gun the wicker ultimate
ashen bullets and flicks every one
second so submachine gun you could just
spray and pray
right if you inflict ash on most of
those enemies and it hangs out for a
while
and then say your build makes ash last
longer you can do this to more things
and then you have an armor mod where
instead of consuming the burn
you consume ash to have overheat go into
effect
so you can literally freeze everybody in
place they're frozen
and then now you're overheat which you
can get your cooldowns crazy low
and now that all the enemies you just
walked in that's like
one thing like and that's not even like
the optimization of all the stuff that's
gonna go into it so
then the same thing bleeds gonna work
the same way for a devastator
and one of the perks honestly it's a
tier two perk and that's what goes into
the build
pretty similarity
[Music]
but after you see what some of these
perks can do you're like the perks on
destiny weapons are so
tame it's too powerful we have to
yeah you see this stuff you know like oh
my god it's they're different games the
but like these perks are so much fun but
there is a perk
critical shots do not consume ammo
final question were you going in depth
with the crafting aspect or you kind of
left that part a little because i heard
the crafted is deep too
crafting is insanely deep i will say
early on
you may be like hey i actually got a
cool weapon i'm really
let some of the stuff go for a little
while guys this is especially for
cognito
let it go dude what should be oh you
think i'm applying
my uh by my destiny um yes i do
but but like how would it apply here
like you'd be like you're saying you can
take
like level nine what's your level right
now 14 or what you say yeah so
you can take a level 14 weapon and you
can level it up as you build your
character you can always bump
one thing up that's kind of the way i
play in
in in i thought you wouldn't want me to
do that i don't want you
to because it's a waste of currency for
so long that's all i'm saying it's like
no no i literally
i get so excited with something new
happens oh that's good but it's like
some people might be like hey this is
starting to fall into my play style
when you get into that point there may
be some things but still for a while it
is not worth the titanium you'll get
more titanium
later but at a low level like titanium
you're gonna start swimming in
expeditions but for a while like moving
mods you can do that all the time it's
pretty cheap right because you break
down weapons you break down armor you're
gonna get leather and iron and i have
more of that than i may ever need i
don't know
um so you can swap mods right so like if
hey this thing's working let me swap one
mod out like swapping armor mods to play
with your play style
do that all the time there's no problem
in that
and now i gotta break it down it would
the model
removed from the thing and you keep the
mod right correct you only have to do it
once
mods are not consumable you unlock it
statue period
permanent right no the only thing is
like if you're going to break anything
down
make sure the mod is unlocked first or
like if you're gonna sell anything
make sure it's unlocked first and then
the same with modding don't
overwrite something you haven't unlocked
yet no you're right
see that what's happening to me is i'll
find armor pieces and stuff that have
mods that i like and once i get
something stronger
i'll put on the stronger thing but i'm
forgetting
i got don't just like you gotta what is
it you gotta dismantle it you have to do
it
so for weapons and armor if you wanna
unlock a mod
you'll know if you've unlocked it ever
if like there's the name of the mod and
on the other side of like the little
weapon or armor window there's this
little two by two little
black box that means you've unlocked it
and it's available in crafting
if that's not there dismantle it
and join over right anyway you can
dismantle you can literally dismantle
everything
but the reason i say that is it's also
good to build up some scrap
yeah so once you know like hey if i'm
looking at a you know an epic weapon but
i've already unlocked both mods i'm
going to sell it
because i have enough iron i have enough
leather i don't need to
and scrap you can use to buy you can use
to buy titanium later on and it's
actually pretty valuable so that's why
it's like i'm going to do i think the
crafting video's got to come tomorrow
my build may come sunday yeah yeah i'm
going to need that video because i'm
still
confused because my thing is i wasn't
sure
should i be dismantling or should i be
selling as far as
once i got the mod so you're saying just
well it's
going to be once you have them i mean
like you can do a little bit if your
inventory is getting full dismantle it
down slowly build up your iron and
leather so you've got a decent amount
you're going to kill enough beasts
leather is going to start getting to me
more
um but i mean if you have like 10 000
iron and leather or whatever
you're good for a little while because
switching mods may be like
190 or 450 you don't need a crap ton but
scrap
is actually useful to buy other stuff
later on but i will also say don't go to
a vendor and buy much stuff you're
always going to get something else like
don't waste the money early either so
yeah
be careful with your resources early
because
like if you do start stockpiling stuff
up later on maybe there's this one thing
and i go to a vendor and they're selling
an epic item
and there's a mod that i haven't seen
yet i was like oh cool i could buy that
it's not really going to hurt my income
and i can unlock the mod because i'm not
really going to use it
right so that's those pieces um i got
that yeah there's i
agree a lot of word vomit that can come
out of me about this game right now
he's happy
i mean honestly for me i was i applied
to get a code for another game
didn't pan out the game didn't stick
around for very long was kind of
drug through the mud we were i was lucky
enough to get invited to the ass
ambassador program shout out to square
enix nelstar psycho cat all of the
community managers
emma park from uh the fourth floor all
of you guys are amazing
um and honestly the community managers
right now are just trying to like put up
the walls to take all why are the
servers down everybody's like
the live service game it's going to take
a while that's normal but
to when i played the demo because i kept
looking i was like it's got potential
it's got potential
when i put 60 hours in the demo i was
like it's definitely there
and then as i said i saw i did get a
couple legendaries i was like i could
see how this
and i got the one legendary that had
doesn't consume ammo i was like
can you picture this on a sniper and
then it just started rolling in my mind
and it played out the way i wanted it to
and i'm just
like yep it it hit on the notes that i
wanted to
are there stutters on pc yes have the
servers have been down that's a live
service game
is the story going to win for everybody
no but it's got some fun moments if you
go see them all
um it's a cool sci-fi it's a decent
sci-fi story it's very serviceable
uh is the shooting destiny it's not
first person none of it's ever gonna
quite be
but i will say generally it's pretty fun
yeah like for fun factor for me just the
way it feels right now in expeditions
this is just like
12 out of 10. yeah yeah just absolute
fun as hell
yeah yeah live service not live service
yeah
and i haven't even done multiplayer so
wow and that's where the most fun is i'm
telling you bro oh yeah when i was
playing with guys that they were playing
so they were like yo
this encounter feels so different now
that y'all scale
because of the thing yeah scales yeah
and they do a good job most games
not necessarily get that part down
either and it seems that they
yeah they did a good job they didn't get
a job so far man i i i agree i think you
were
on to something i'm i'm glad to see it
be received
generally well it's not perfect it has
some six glitches you know you can see
some of the like i mean it's just like
how much do you care about certain
things when the gun playing armor and
weapons
right the combat is what wins the game
are there
things in other places yes i'm not gonna
say it's perfect
but it's like for me the fun factor is
10.
if i was gonna rate the game and again i
haven't played this on a ps4 with a
spinning hard drive
right i don't know what that would be
like i know what that is
i can tell you what that is because
shout out i hate to i hate the console
shame a couple of brothers buying but i
was playing
my boy uh reeves and my boy demon and
one is on a
xbox i'm on a series x one is on a one x
and one is on a vcr xbox
one yeah what i've got upstairs that's
my media player yeah right
now what i noticed is when i host
like you know when you go in between
areas yep
my joint will go voom 80
and stop wait on them waiting on them
god forbid they get a disconnect mid
game
oh lord i just like that we just gotta
wait you know
sometimes we had to wait for it we seen
his his name
and we had to wait for his character to
materialize
and it took a while so but like god
blessed her for even making this thing
possible that i could play with the vcr
dudes you don't say salute to them
but yo it's serviceable i mean i i can't
say it's not once it's working it's
working and
stuff like that but playing as a series
x
yeah i didn't have and cross play it's
right now between play s5 and series
consoles and then you can play you can't
cross the streams right now
yes facts good funny term
terminology there you just use your
generate code you you open your privacy
settings
you put the generate code they jump in
instantly that was impressive i was like
okay
now again the only thing that the pc
guys right now i don't know what the
service is a steam or something
they're having a ton of disconnect
issues so they just got to work that out
but my ps5 guys we were rocking we did a
whole mission
together it was it was like oh and no
only thing though is no
and i hope destiny takes note if you're
gonna do cross play
you gotta have cross chat
in game yeah they don't have that yeah
there's no
there's no chat yeah you got to be you
got to find a discord or something to go
talk to you like myself
or get your phone ready next to the yeah
yeah old school on the phone yep
absolutely that's it
i know i talked a lot i could still keep
talking for way too damn long so
yeah i'm going to wrap it up for now i
want at least cognito to kind of
see when he gets through the story we'll
see if he gets through the next week you
got some time
um and go but yeah this is pretty much
what we got for the podcast
um obviously right now outriders has my
focus it's a lot of fun yes i think
these gentlemen well are gonna be
playing it and enjoying
and honestly i think it came out at a
perfect time yeah that's like absolutely
that's the last little like
asterisk of what came out around april
1st not a
damn thing right now people were
ravenous for something new
and there's nothing else like even death
loop is somewhere in may like
six weeks later and i gotta say game
pass this game in game pass oh dude that
is huge
bro i mean yeah a whole list is playing
it
it i know people who keep saying i
wasn't gonna buy this game
i wasn't sure about this game and the
fact that it's in there
bro i am seeing people like oh my god i
love this game
oh my god like tremendous and then you
throw the cross play yes there's some
issues but yeah they're working on it
they
they got they got something man they got
something for a foundation they got
something
it's very impressive so yeah i agree you
said it perfect the timing too
perfect you know let's be real was
nothing going on destiny week no news
story beat to pull us away
so it's kind of like it's the perfect
guy to go get in there see what's up and
have some fun
it's like people are ravenous for a game
like this
everybody was worried about the anthem
vibes everybody's worried about
yeah anthem was the big one i think i
heard everybody because they had the
sci-fi feel and they're like
got some of the loot is it no this has
got everything you want it's gonna have
a start to a finish story that makes
sense
you're gonna know what the ending is
when you get there and then there's an
in-game grind if you want it
that is like a diablo paragon level
thing and i think that's
for what you buy and what you get or
what you get with game pass
yeah yeah if this thing ever falls off a
game pass
that's one of those like as this is not
a there are no micro
transactions period right right so like
whatever
bag of money whatever was involved when
it comes to
you know game pass i would love to know
what
those this is one especially because
there is no live service no micro
transactions no nothing
they just jump in and play this is one
of those that makes me wonder how game
pass financially works because
like for them to say hey xbox everybody
on xbox is going to have it one x series
all of us are good to go and it's just
like
if you're on xbox you probably do
already and if you don't you're dumb
right and even on pc it's not there but
like if you got a console
you get this game it's so big yeah it
says like and it's just like
for them i'm just so happy that it was
successful because yeah
man you can tell that a lot was put into
this somebody in my chat said it pretty
well
because we were going over some of the
perks on the legendaries and they're
like did they just have everybody in the
company just write all the crazy perks
they said on the board
and then like the execs came in and be
like all right crank these up to about
times two and put them all in the game
yeah
and that's what that's in there yeah
yeah there's no restriction it feels odd
fun
they they don't care if you break it
they don't care
if the boss melts in five seconds
because you're built
have at it and it pops
[Laughter]
and that's the refreshing feel right
that's what we missed that's what we've
been kind of clamoring from
from destiny and that it's a cool
contrast it's a cool cot to just
let your head out and just have at it
yep have at it
you know go totally crazy so yeah and
it's
you know it's just it's newer that's why
some people are saying it's like we're
talking about the engine and this that
and the other destiny is how many years
old at this point still
they keep updating the back end and back
end but this is
you know going to be built on ue4 it's
on ue something so it's just it's able
to
handle obviously just the bananas
craziness going on so
yeah it does seem to think it does make
me think that
yeah destiny needs some type of decent
update and
yeah this is this is the one that will
make people be like well this did
this hey destiny can you add this yes
it's got
quite a few it may not be perfect but
it's got a lot of things though to make
should be like
well i hope this is in every game going
forward right and like i said we all
agree
competition this is where it puts
pressure on things we love
to actually you know what i'm saying
improve and and now there's a there's a
quality of life there's a ui there's a
that fun factor of just going all out
and not worrying about
you know these power creep stuff like
versus you don't say
yeah listen we we gonna see this is go i
love stuff like that competition is
always good
yeah this is i think gonna be a really
good thing if you want a point of
reference of something that did it well
i think they did i think they launched
absolutely a big
i don't know of a number to put on it
but in my mind it's a big w
so oh yeah that's that's yeah their
first shot out
hell yeah definite w definite w
absolutely we've seen a lot of these
loudest shooters come and go and no this
is a strong
foundation start good for them yep
that's about all i got uh phillip thank
you man for coming on i know i probably
hogged the show here at the end for out
writers this might be
good
yeah i was like i've got got a lot to
cover but yeah if you guys got questions
let me know
um a little ahead of you it doesn't mean
i know more but it's just
spent way too much time around the world
and it's fun
so but at this point as we wrap things
up
it's your the floor is kind of yours to
let them know what you got coming what
you're working on where they can find
you
basically everything for your world this
is your time to tell them
i'm philip carlisle gaming and all that
stuff pcg
everything floor is yours man all right
so
as you know guys pete carlo gaming here
uh you can find me on twitter
p carla gaming2 uh definitely
had to put that in there um and also you
can also find me
on the last city radio podcast i
definitely
this saturday of course destiny day we
returning back
with me and my guy ronin 503 we're going
to be discussing a lot of things
and where we see destiny i'm going
forward
is these seasons a good thing or they're
bad things so we're going to discuss
that on saturday
and um also you can find me streaming
stream late nights p carl out gaming
definitely on
twitch hit me up guys and definitely uh
come and say hi
hello salute man salute to you brother
as we see e do these
outstanding well-formed sit-ups
we cannot not acknowledge this greatness
that is going on with form and function
look he been playing a lot of outright
is he got to work this off
so good shout out to my boy working out
with your feet man thanks you for
pulling up man um
you know i'm a huge fan of you i think
you got a lot of potential i think
you're one of the positive guys in the
community
and i'm always gonna root for guys like
you to succeed that's doing it the right
way that through
negativity you know past situations in
the past
we ain't going to get into that but yeah
we move forward
and we you know and again we love to
support that man so
salute to you keep up the grind love the
content love the thoughts you had some
great points today
and um yeah man always always love man
definitely have you back in the future
just continue what you're doing brother
i'm saying but you know me
lord cognito you already know the deal
um on twitter
and um podcast no analog podcast this
sunday
um i normally give away the last word
who
we're gonna have i can't in this
situation because it's a really big
secret so all i will say
is no ilp sunday but there will be a
special iop
tuesday at 5 00 p.m eastern so
come check us out it should be very fun
it might surprise some
dominance not i will say if people can
oh this is the philippines
no this is not the fail but i it would
be a pleasant surprise
and i'm i'm super excited you know to
get that going so check us out next week
we'll be fine as we'll technically be
two iops next week no
no i open this week but um yeah man we
appreciate the support and i had to wrap
my
lawyers at gaming.net man today proud of
these guys they are really
killing us with the articles shout out
to the
kana account am i saying it correctly
because we actually had some fun
feedback with them
with the developers of the game and uh
just some april fools i'm really looking
forward to that by the way
yeah me too i'm so excited just to see
you know the site get recognition by a
couple of devs and publishers and stuff
like that
and just trying to put out good content
and like i said um
iop expect more stuff some more fun
stuff and uh yeah man last word
man you already know had to have that
nice last word content i was looking
forward to this episode big time
because of the topics he is out here
killing it with the outrider stuff so
salute to him
let's go to the chat for putting up a
lot of good discussion today and um yeah
man that's what i got but yeah i'll let
you take us
out with what you got going on yeah i
mean for me
depending on if destiny is fairly light
i'm going to be focused a lot on
outriders coverage
for understanding crafting understanding
like
did you know if you get frozen you need
to punch to get out of it
no yep little stuff like that status
effects
if you bleed stand still
yeah didn't know that yep wow so there's
a whole bunch going on with that stuff
so i'm going to be doing pretty much
non-stop videos on that for a while
if anything major happens in destiny but
honestly like at this point
i'm going to be spending a lot of time
in this i think it's going to be a lot
of fun probably play it way too much but
i definitely want to jump into the other
classes and see
so i'll be streaming a lot pretty much
straight out writers for a while
um next one that's probably coming up if
i do like a variety day when this
eventually tapers off might be but ori
and the wild whis will be my next one to
go
so stay tuned you did the fire yeah
that'll probably be like a
two day kind of back to back or probably
done in one week stream
uh about to write the book on outriders
there's a lot of stuff to cover and i'm
not even
and i feel like there's still more so
there's always a little bit more
but overall yeah streaming on twitch
find me on twitter a lot of crap tony
out outriders videos on youtube uh but i
just want to thank uh phillip thank you
very much for coming man appreciate the
time thank you for your insight your
thoughts your positivity and just vibes
for
everything that you do if you guys don't
follow this man please do p
carlislegaming both on twitter and
twitch
right find the last city radio listen to
his podcast
just a nice man to listen to good
positive vibes bringing stuff to
destiny and then just gaming in general
so want to thank you sir for coming
always always a pleasure
thank you i want to say one thing one
psa
the trickster subclass on outriders
that's what background should have been
just saying they're saying
interesting okay that's where you're
going with it the
there's the there's a mod that works
exactly like the mask of backers by the
way
there's a there's a teleport mod
changes you jump now you teleport
through things
that's correct oh great it's just saying
it's there
yeah okay that's why i was like just
when you think you know all the mods
nope there's more
there's so many crazy ones i actually
used that for a while but then
eventually got away from it but it's
actually got some pretty solid value in
the end game it's fun
um but yeah for this episode we know
it's been a long one but outriders
definitely had a pretty deep talk sorry
i kind of stole the table there for a
bit
thank you guys apologizing for what your
great information yeah
absolutely we this is why i wanted to
hear yeah this was great
we needed that for today april 2nd no
longer april
so you can take this one seriously
episode number 143
we're getting up there um thank you guys
very much it's been an awesome one
and for this episode it has been
the last word